[Musique]
top Laurent alexon bonjour bonjour nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle sinkeriew nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter
sucintement alors je suis de formation
médicale j'ai longtemps exercé la la
chirurgie ologique j'ai créé plus d'une
dizaine de startup notamment dans le
domaine de l'informatique et et
maintenant de l'intelligence
artificielle puis j'ai beaucoup écrit
beaucoup d'articles notamment sur les
sujets liés au aux technologies NBIC et
à l'intelligence artificielle et et puis
plusieurs bouquins le dernier étant la
guerre des intelligences à l'heure de
chatgpt édition chez jean-claud latess
combien ça coûte 21 € 90 tu touches
combien en science tutois moi je je
touche rien j'abandonne mes droits
d'auteur pour que le prix soit le plus
faible possible magnifique on a lu le
bouquin ça fait longtemps qu'on s'est
pas
vu je me suis régalé avec le bouquin
c'est à la fois un bouquin qui fait un
constat de la prospective et un peu de
science-fiction
et je veux qu'on en parle c'est
important c'est important que les gens
comprennent votre ou ton point de vue de
ton ta perception il y a beaucoup de
recherch dedans euh il y a il y a un
gros travail d'interprétation des
recherches et d'extrapolation des
recherches pourquoi la guerre des
intelligences parce que à l'heure de
l'intelligence artificiel et de
l'extrême complexité du monde
l'intelligence devient la source de tous
les pouvoirs de toutes les guerres et
qu'il
s'agisse du domaine géopolitique ou
qu'il s'agisse de l'économie domestique
l'intelligence va être au cœur de tous
les process de tous les conflits de
toutes les guerres et donc la guerre des
intelligences c'est pas avec un point
d'interrogation en réalité c'est avec un
point
d'exclamation qu'est-ce qui va se passer
pour la population là là j'ai vu très
récemment que il y a une boîte qui fait
appel à de l'intelligence artificielle
pour faire de la veille médiatique il y
a euh je demande à me faire fact checker
euh au moins les 2 tiers de la société
qui vont qui va subir un un plan de
licenciement
massif on en est qu'au début est-ce que
vous ou est-ce que tu as creusé les
choses est-ce que tu as vu des pistes
des solutions pour endiguer ça et
quelles vont être les solutions des
politiques pour aller avoir avec un peu
plus de calme social j'ai pas terminé la
question c'est est-ce que les gens
inadaptés vont être obligés d'être
perfusés de subvention de filet social
jusqu'à la fin de leur jour jusqu'à
l'Pad pour maintenir une cohésion
sociale mais d'abord il faudrait savoir
où on va atterrir en matière
d'intelligence artificielle on a une
très grande
imprévisibilité le 29 novembre 2022
c'estd la veille de la sortie de chat
GPT 3.5 alors pour ceux qui ne savent
pas chat GPT 3.5 c'est quoi c'est la
première version de de de chat GPT
produit par open donc la veille de la
sortie de de cette version
révolutionnaire de GPT euh ce que fait
aujourd'hui gpt4 en médecine je
n'imaginais pas que ce soit possible
avant 2035
2050 comme tout le monde euh quand on
donne un dossier médical avec des
abréviations des
fautes en plusieurs langues avec de
l'argot du patoi ch GPT 4 il fait un
diagnostic ça c'est quelque chose que je
n'imaginais pas possible avant 15 20 30
ans donc c'est assez difficile
aujourd'hui de savoir jusqu'où va aller
l'intelligence artificielle d'ici 2030
2040 2050 en rité il y a trois scénarios
le premier scénario l'intelligence
artificielle se développe mais elle
n'atteint pas ce qu'on appelle l'g et
l'intelligence artificielle générale
c'est-à-dire qu'elle ne dépasse pas
l'intelligence humaine dans toutes les
dimensions le deuxième scénario c'est
que dans 1000 à 2000 jours
l'intelligence artificielle devienne une
intelligence artificielle générale et
donc dépasse l'intelligence humaine dans
toutes les dimensions intellectuelles et
cognitives puis le troisème scénario
c'est le scénario qui a été annoncé par
Sam Altman le fondateur de chat GPT il
est cet été c'est le scénario dans
lequel nous atteignons la super
intelligence artificielle d'ici
2030 ces trois scénarios dessinent pour
nous à titre individuel pour nos
familles pour nos entreprises pour la
société pour l'humanité en général pour
la France pour la France bien sûr des
destins différents si l'intelligence
artificielle se se développe mais ne
dépasse pas l'intelligence humaine dans
toutes les dimensions on va avoir une
révolution chumpéterrienne
traditionnelle comme a été l'électricité
la vapeur ou le moteur à
explosion c'est une révolution
chumpetterrienne c'est déjà beaucoup
mais ce n'est pas un bouleversement en
réalité fantastique si le deuxème
scénario se révèle juste c'est-à-dire
que on atteint l'intelligence
artificielle générale dans 1000 à 2000
jours ce qui est le scénario aujourd'hui
privilégié par à peu près 80 % des
experts là on a non plus une révolution
chumpéterrienne mais on a un changement
civilisationnel c'est une réorganisation
complète de la société qui est à
l'horizon de 2030 2035 puis le trème
scénario aujourd'hui privilégié par le
créateur de chat GPT c'est l'arrivée
rapide de la super intelligence cette
fois-ci ça n'est plus
une révolution civilisationnelle un
changement civilisationnel c'est un
changement anthropologique c'est un
changement dans le statut de l'homme qui
serait totalement cette fois-ci
marginalisé par l'intelligence
artificielle donc et aujourd'hui les
experts ont changé d'avis très vite il y
a 1 an
80 % des experts pensaient que
l'intelligence artificielle ne
dépasserait pas rapidement
l'intelligence humaine 10 % pensaient
que l'intelligence artificielle générale
arriverait d'ici ici 2030 et 5 à 10
% imaginit que on aurait de la super
intelligence dans les années où les où
les décennies qui viennent aujourd'hui
c'est plutôt 10 % pour le scénario 1 80
% pour le scénario 2 et 10 % pour le
scénario 3 donc les experts se sont
rallés à l'idée que l'intelligence
artificielle générale supérieure au
cerveau humain dans toutes les
dimensions intellectuelles va arriver
relativement rapidement c'est ça
signifie quelque chose c'est qu'en rité
il est très très difficile de prévoir ce
qui va se passer technologiquement et et
et pour le politique de savoir ce qu'il
faut faire on voit bien que pour
l'adaptation des travailleurs le
scénario 1 le scénario 2 et le scénario
3 ont des conséquences extrêmement
différente le scénario 3 est un scénario
dans lequel même les intellectuels même
les gens les plus innovants pourraient
être marginalisés par l'intelligence
artificielle alors que le scénario 1 est
un scénario dans lequel l'adaptation ne
serait pas trop difficile alors samalman
qui pense que l'intelligence
artificielle super intelligence
artificielle est là bientôt est en train
de lancer une expérimentation à grande
échelle de revenus universel parce qu'il
est convaincu qu'une très large partie
de la population ne va pas pouvoir
s'adapter ne va pas être compétitif face
à l'intelligence artificielle et il
pense que seul le revenu universel va
pouvoir occuper ces gens-là l'idée de
mettre au revenu universel les gens
dépassés par les successeurs de gpt4 euh
s'accompagne chez certains experts de la
la silicone valleée de l'idée de donner
la réalité virtuelle gratuite
c'est-à-dire que il y aurait un paackage
revenu universel pour les gens dépassés
par l'intelligence artificielle et puis
réalité virtuelle c'est les casqueoculus
et les programmes qui vont avec pour
occuper les gens pour les gens qui ne
pourraient plus travailler
personnellement je suis totalement
opposé à à à cette stratégie je pense
que
l'idée politique qui auar qui a qui
apparaî sympathique et bienveillante du
revenu universel est une idée mortifère
et inacceptable politiquement parce que
l'idée de mettre au revenu universel les
gens moins malins et moins intelligents
que chat GPT dans le futur à la sortie
de l'école jusqu'au moment où il rentre
chez Orpa est juste un cauchemar
politique est un cauchemar chez Orpa et
chez les concurrents d'orpa est un
cauchemar politique donc je ne crois pas
qu'une société dans lequel tous les gens
dépassés par l'intelligence artificielle
seraient mis au rebut au revenu
universel jusqu'à leur mort est une est
une société tenable je pense qu'il faut
davantage réfléchir dans l'adaptation de
l'ensemble des citoyens à la nouvelle
donne cognitive intellectuelle plutôt
que de les mettre de côté je suis très
inquiet de ces expérimentations de
revenu universel décidé à à à employer
une vie entière les gens des passer par
l'intelligence artificielle je je pense
que ce
serait un monde à la Métropolis qui se
dessine un monde absolument atroce je
pense qu'il faut davantage réfléchir à
la formation et à l'adaptation de tout
le monde à cette nouvelle technologie
avant de rentrer dans des cas concrets
de ce qu'on peut faire avec tout ça
parce que il y a certains ou certains
auditeurs ou auditrices n'ont pas
conscience des des capacités déjà à
l'heure actuelle de C de
ces la régulation est-ce qu'elle est un
peu pensée est-ce que l'encadrement est
un peu pensé est-ce que on entend si une
intelligence artificielle s'échappe euh
si une intelligence artificielle se sent
si elle émettrait elle émettait des des
des sentiments des sensations de
captivité ou des véléités de
développement comment comment on fait
pour encadrer est-ce qu'il y a un
conseil d'éthique est-ce qu'il y a
quelque chose qui se met en place
alors la régulation ne peut pas être à
l'échelle duumain et Loire ou de la
ville de Carpentra ou d'Alsace une
régulation sur l'intelligence
artificielle ne peut-être que mondiale
évidemment à partir du moment où on a
une intelligence artificielle générale
qui dépasse l'intelligence humaine alors
on a vu l'excitation dans la Silicon
vallée et au-delà de la silicone
vallleée chez les experts depuis
quelques semaines avec la déclaration
cet été de de 26 de 26 mots hein le le
statement la déclaration de 26 mot mot
qui explique signé par Bill Gates signé
par Sam Altman le fondateur de chat GPT
et de nombreux expert de l'intelligence
artificielle
déclaration selon laquelle pour réduire
le risque de d'extermination de
l'humanité par l'intelligence
artificielle il faut une prise de
conscience mondiale global en anglais au
même titre qu'on a une réflexion pour
réduire les risques de pandémie et pour
contrôler les dangers de de de guerre
nucléire donc il y a un petite phase
d'hystérie dans la Silicon valleée de du
fait des progrès très très importants
depuis 10 mois des des réseaux neurone
de de type chat GPT et il y a une
demande de la part des experts de
régulation à l'échelle mondiale euh une
réunion s'est tenue au au au Congrès
américain cette semaine avec la totalité
des grands industriels de l'intelligence
artificielle pour réclamer une
régulation sous la forme d'une agence
fédérale comme il y a une agence
fédérale du de contrôle boursier une
agence fédérale du droit de la
concurrence une agence fédérale pour la
euh pour l'aviation civile et cetera et
cetera euh il y a une demande de la part
des industriels d'une
régulation au niveau américain dans un
premier temps pour gérer les
développements rapides de l'intelligence
artificielle pour éviter l'extermination
de l'humanité ça veut dire
quoi une partie des spécialistes de
l'intelligence
artificielle pense qu'elle va devenir
dangereuse c'est notamment le cas de
hintton qui est le père des
intelligences artificielles sous la
forme des réseaux de neurones hein à
Toronto qui a d'ailleurs dans une
déclaration cet été dit que si c'était à
refaire il ne voudrait pas avoir inventé
les réseaux de neuron artificiel car il
les juge trop dangereux pour l'avenir
euh de de l'humanité donc une
dangerosité sous quelle forme alors
destruction de la démocratie parce que
les fake news vont pouvoir être
totalement crédibles il y a des vidéos
de Macron extraordinaires qui circulent
en ce moment une notamment faite par
l'équipe d'anuna où on voit Macron
raconter n'importe quoi avec des
mouvements des lèvres parfaits un un
petit logiciel extraordinaire est sorti
il y a quelques jours
gen qui permet de de de transformer une
vidéo dans une langue en une vidéo dans
n'importe quelle langue et qui adapte
les mouvements des lèvres à la nouvelle
langue il y a plein de vidéos sur les
réseaux sociaux qui qui circulent comme
ça donc première crainte la destruction
de de la démocratie par la mort du réel
la mort de la vérité parce que on va
pouvoir créer plein de vérités
alternatives avec des
vidéos les gens qui voudront manipuler
déformer le le débat public les plotiste
comme on les appelle pas parfois donc il
y a cette crainte par rapport par
rapport à la à la démocratie pu il y a
une deuxième crainte qui est une crainte
par rapport au monde du travail une
partie des experts de l'intelligence
artificielle et notamment Sam Altman le
fondateur de chat GPT pense que la
formation des travailleurs et l'école ne
vont pas être assez rapides pour que les
gens puissent galoper derrière
l'intelligence artificielle et donc il y
a la crainte d'un bouleversement social
et donc politique à cause de
l'intelligence artificielle enfin la
troisième crainte c'est une crainte
d'arrivée d'e nia hostile il y a pas du
tout de consensus là-dessus il y a des
gens comme Yann Lequin qui est l'un des
grands spécialistes mondiaux de
l'intelligence artificielle et qui est
le responsable de l'IA chez Facebook MTA
qui considère que ces craintes sont
complètement grotesques il décrit non
pas la mort de l'humanité à cause de
l'intelligence artificielle mais une
nouvelle Renaissance et un nouveau
siècle des Lumières grâce à tout le
potentiel de l'intelligence artificielle
donc il y a pas il y a pas de consensus
entre ceux qui tiennent un discours très
pessimiste sur les risques d'hostilité
de l'intelligence artificielle et ceux
qui trouvent que c'est complètement con
comme y Lequin et qui et qui voit
principalement les aspects positifs et
révolutionnaires de l'IA et qui minimise
les risques d'un vrai conflit
c'est-à-dire d'une guerre des
intelligences pour de bon entre li et
nous en terme de processus créatif quel
impact ça peut
avoir en terme éducatif en
terme de développement de des cerveaux
de nos chers de nos chers hubains nos
chers enfants est-ce que l'intelligence
artificielle couplé à un enseignement
traditionnel peut aider est-ce que ça va
changer
la l'arborescence de la pensée
humaine l'intelligence artificielle va
forcément changer la façon dont on pense
car nous sommes dans un nombre croissant
de domaines dépés donc si nous voulons
exister ne pas aller au revenus
universel il va falloir qu'on se casse
le cul et qu'on bosse un peu pour être
complémentaire de l'intelligence
artificielle chacun d'entre nous doit
passer plusieurs heures par semaine à
réfléchir à sa complémentarité avec
l'intelligence artificielle pourquoi pas
l'inverse parce que c'est nous qui
sommes challengés c'est pas
l'intelligence artificielle qui est
challengé
euh nous avons cet effort à faire parce
que l'intelligence artificielle
progresse très vite alors que le cerveau
humain ne progresse pas aussi vite aussi
vite bah il progresse très peu je vais
prendre juste un exemple en
médecine chat GPT est égal ou supérieur
à au médecin dans un nombre croissant tu
peux me redresser
ton c'est bon comme ça que l'ingénieur
de son valide ça va là magnifique désol
pour cette coupure dans dans dans le
domaine de la médecine g
pT4 atteint le niveau des médecins et et
parfois les dépassent dans un nombre
croissant de de de de discipline en
terme de diagnostic et de choix et de
choix
thérapeutique il y a un vrai challenge
pour ma profession je peux couper oui en
terme de de de challenge thérapeutique
ok mais un médecin qui s'adresse à son
patient qui prend en considération le
biotope familial la vie du patient sa
perception est-ce que on n pas en train
en train de transformer le contact la
relation passion médecin est-ce qu'on
est pas en train de la standardiser
comme des poulets un mot un mot
chaleureux d'un médecin oui alors c'est
c'est ce que ma profession et beaucoup
de professions imaginent la technique
les chiffres à l'intelligence
artificielle
l'empathie le C la gentillesse la
bienveillance à nous sauf que une étude
qui vient d'être publié dans l'une des
plus grandes revues médicales montre que
les médecins et bien sont moins
empathiques que l'intelligence
artificielle c'est une certitude
ouais mais moi j'imaginais plutôt le
contraire mais c'est sans doute parce
que je suis médecin et donc dans cette
étude l'intelligence artificielle
dépasse les médecins en terme technique
en terme clinique mais surtout elle a
une note deux fois supérieure à la note
des médecins en terme d'empathie donc
l'idée selon laquelle nous médecin on va
abandonner la complexité technique àa et
qu'on va s'occuper euh de la
bienveillance de l'empathie et de la
gentillesse c'est une idée conne une
idée fausse parce qu'en réalité lia est
plus empathique que nous mais on aurait
pu s'en douter quand il est 12h30 et
qu'on voit le dernier
patient et qu'on a envie d'aller bouffer
et qu'on a notre femme qui nous attend
parce qu'on bouffe avec notre femme ou
ou ou ou ou pour les femmes le
contraire au bout de 20 minutes de
consultation le malade on lui dit
gentiment qu'on va le revoir dans
quelques jours avec gpt4 on peut parler
de sa maladie jour et nuit pendant une
semaine si on veut gpt4 va être toujours
bienveillant gentil ne va jamais se
lasser va répéter s'il faut répéter à
l'infini on aurait dû se douter que
notre supériorité sur l'empathie était
un leure était illusoir c'est choquant
moi je n'imaginais pas que lia serait
plus empathique que nous docteur mais
c'est ce qui est en train de se réaliser
s'il a un gros coup de Massu sur la tête
y compris pour moi je ne pensais pas que
nous serions challenger à cette vitesse
là y compris sur la dimension de la
bienveillance et de
l'empathie alors cette empathie médicale
que l'intelligence artificielle tel que
tu le décris à une meilleure sensibilité
une meilleure perception ça vient de
quoi ça vient du fait que les réseaux de
neuron perçoivent le moindre caractère
du patient dans son visage dans son
attitude dans sa démarche dans sa façon
de marcher son rythme cardiaque sa
production d'adrénaline laamidriase ou
pas laamidriase pardon la dilatation de
de l'iris ou pas alors pour l'instant
pour l'instant ces paramètres ne sont
pas
intégrés mais l'intelligence artifelle
est capable de répondre aux questions de
façon très patiente comme dans le film
her en réalité gpt4 ressemble énormément
à he sauf sauf la fin du film on a SPO
pas on a atteint on a atteint le niveau
veau d'empathie et et la qualité de
réponse qu'on a dans le film her et
c'est ça qui donne cette impression de
bienveillance et et d'empathie chez les
patients même si
gpt4 n'a pas de
conscience et reste un algorithme
inconscient et une étude récente montre
qu'il n'y a pas d'émergence de la
conscience chez chat GPT même si les
experts considèrent que une intelligence
artificielle dotée de conscience est
possible mais ça n'est pas encore le cas
de chat GPT donc donc à ta question
comment on s'adapte sur le plan
professionnel il y a du boulot il va
falloir qu'on qu'on passe du temps et
quand je dis il faut passer quelques
heures par semaine chacun d'entre nous à
réfléchir c'est pas une blague ceux qui
ne vont pas réfléchir à l'adaptation à
l'intelligence artificielle vont-être
noyé je vais prendre un exemple
personnel je me suis posé la question
récemment quelle est la proportion du
savoir médical que je connais en 2023 je
passe beaucoup de temps à me former je
passe beaucoup de temps à lire et
j'estime que je connais à peu près 1
millionè du savoir médical un pas 1
milli 1 millionième donc la part du
savoir médical que je connais est très
très très
marginale comment quand je vais
connaître un milliardième du savoir
médical peut-être en 2030 ou en 2035
comment je
peux être complémentaire de
l'intelligence artificielle garder une
place dans le processus décisionnel
médical pour pour les patients c'est une
vraie question il y a pas de réponse
simple et c'est vrai dans tous les
métiers si tu prends les gens qui font
du doublage cinéma l'intelligence
artificielle dont on parlait tout à
l'heure là gen qui est capable de
changer la langue automatiquement en
gardant en gardant la
voix de la premiè de la première vidéo
va très probablement conduire en peu
d'années au au départ de tous les
doubleurs parce que l'avantage par
rapport au doubleurs traditionnel c'est
que ça modifie automatiquement les
mouvements des vre sans avoir à changer
le le le le texte et que ça
donne la ça donne l'accent la voix de la
première personne c'est dire qu'on est
on est capable d'avoir har sonford qui
parle français mais avec la voix d'h
Harrison Ford et les intonations
d'Harrison Ford c'est
extraordinairecion il y a il y a il y a
une vidéo d'Elon Mosk là qui parle en
japonais en français dans plein de
langues c'est la vraie voix d'Elon
mosque alors que dans un doublage on on
a pas la voix de l'acteur on a un
doubleur qui a sa propre voix sa propre
intonation on pourrait multiplier les
exemples de de ces challenge pour ce qui
concerne les cadres y compris les cadres
dirigeants les dernières études montrent
que dans le processus
créatif chat GPT dans sa version 4 et
ses équivalents sont très innovants une
étude qui est sortie dans le Wall Street
Journal la semaine dernière montre
que
gpt4
écrabouille les étudiants du NBA de
Wharton qui est le troè meilleur NBA au
monde les écrabouill sur les processus
créatifs et innovants euh 35 victoires
pour gpt4 5 victoires pour les étudiants
du MBA d Warton qui sont des des
étudiants d'un niveau absolument
exceptionnel donc même pour la création
et l'innovation ce qu'on pensait être un
de nos derniers territoires
l'intelligence artificielle est est est
excellente un papier qui est sorti dans
dans dans une des revues de nature hier
va dans le même sens et montre que seul
les humains les plus doués arrivent à
être compétitifs dans les processus
créatifs avec l'intelligence
artificielle donc le problème concerne
l'ensemble de la société concerne chacun
d'entre nous il y a un effort absolument
gigantesque à faire pour le système de
formation professionnel et pour l'école
mais comme l'école est à la ramasse
comme le système de formation continue
des adultes la ramasse c'est à chacun
d'entre nous dans nos familles de de
faire ce travail et de se préparer à ce
tsunami parce que la transformation sur
l'organisation du travail va être
absolument colossale dans dans les
années qui viennent je je rembobine un
peu sur les interprètes les traducteurs
les doubleurs quand on fait des des
émissions avec des des étrangers qui ne
parlent pas français on on engage à
chaque fois des des interprètes qualité
nations- Unies pourquoi pourquoi je te
dis ça parce que on veut absolument que
les questions soient traduites
correctement y compris avec un langage
vernaculaire s'il faut avoir le langage
vernaculaire quel problème de sécurité
ça peut créer par exemple au Nations
Unies si la il y a une faute si
l'entraînement de l'intelligence
artificielle pose problème il y aura pas
de problème d'entraînement en revanche
quelqu'un pourrait hacker l'intelligence
artificielle pour [__] le bordel entre
deux états pourrait transformer la
déclaration de Macron en traduisant mal
exprès pour qu'il tiennent des propos
contre telle ou telle religion de
manière à [__] le bordel au sel on
pourrait imaginer des tas de
manipulations mais ce ne serait pas un
problème lié à la qualité de liya ce
serait un problème lié au haaking c'est
dire au à à à la à une utilisation à une
utilisation maline à une piraterie des
systèmes de de de de de de traduction
mais si on prend ton métier qui est
diffusé de l'information on se rend
compte que ce métier était segmenté par
zone
linguistique on ne pouvait pas avoir
dans le monde entier Serview tu fais une
audience extraordinaire tu dépasses
assez régulièrement 1 million de vues
sur tes interviews mais ça reste Franco
franchouillard ça ne concerne que le bac
à sable francophone sur le plan
linguistique c'est pas un
c'est un gros bac à sable mais c'est un
bac à sable quand même demain tu vas
pouvoir transformer cette émission en la
même en polonais en gardant la même
intonation des voix mais en polonais
avec une des mouvements des lèvres qui
vont être parfaits tu vas pouvoir le
faire en anglais en allemand en
serbocroate en arabe en chinois à un
coup qui est juste nul et en quelques
minutes de manipulation donc ton métier
va se globaliser va se mondialiser c'est
aussi la même chose pour les consultants
quand tu es consultant tu n'es pas
capable de de faire du conseil en
stratégie au Brésil quand tu n'es pas
lusitanophone demain tu vas le pouvoir
donc les services vont se mondialiser ça
va avoir des conséquences très
importantes pour la diffusion des
messages avec la possibilité de de
parler à la terre entière au lieu de
parler uniquement à sa zone linguistique
on pourrait multiplier les exemples de
conséquences de C ces technologies là
euh de conséquence extrêmement positives
dans le cas de de de la traduction qui
va permettre de créer un marché mondial
unifié de la connaissance et de
l'information TF1 c'est fini TF1
n'existera demain que si elle utilise
ces logiciels là pour être traduit dans
la totalité des langues mondiales sinon
elle va être noyée par les autres
chaînes de télévision dans le monde qui
elles vont se traduire dans toutes les
langues pour diffusé partout je rebobine
encore un coup et ensuite on fera avance
rapide sur un autre
sujet tu parlais d'empathie je vais te
parler de soins
palliatifs une main qui tient une autre
main pour accompagner est-ce que tu vois
l'intelligence artificielle remplacer
cette relation
là alors je pense que l'intelligence
artificielle peut nous aider à réduire
le
champ de la médecine palliative une
partie importante de la médecine
palliative aujourd'hui ce sont les
cancéreux en Phe terminale alors nous
guérissons 80 % des enfants cancéreux et
55 % des adultes cancéreux mais il y a
encore 20 % d'enfants cancéreux qui
meurent et il y a encore 45 % des
adultes cancéreux qui meurent j'ai fait
dans ma vie pas mal de de de chirurgies
dans le domaine de la cancérologie j'ai
eu hélas à
soigner beaucoup de patients qui avaient
des cancers c'est l'intelligence
artificielle qui va nous permettre de
gagner les les derniers kilomètres et
qui va nous permettre de d'arriver à 100
% de guérison ou de rémission longue des
cancers comme on l'a fait sur le sida on
ne guérit pas le sida mais il y a
quasiment plus personne dans les pays
développés qui meurent du sida nous
allons faire la même chose grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle nous allons
transformer les formes très très graves
et mortelles de cancer en des maladies
chroniques comme le sida est devenu une
maladie chronique avec les tri et et
quadrithérapie donc je pense que
l'intelligence artificielle son rôle
principal n'est pas de tenir la main des
cancéreux en Phe terminale avant qu'on
leur mette un cocktail litique pour les
endormir je pense que le rôle de
l'intelligence artificielle est de nous
aider à à guérir 100 % des cancéreux
adultes et et enfants et ça n'est pas
quelque chose duutopique parce que le
cancer est incroyablement compliqué dans
une tumeur il y a des millions de
mutations génétiques différentes c'est
très très compliqué pour un cerveau
humain de comprendre toutes les
interactions biologiques dans la cellule
cancéreuse l'intelligence artificielle
va beaucoup nous aider d'ailleurs si on
parle biologie il faut pour déterminer
la structure en trois dimension d'une
d'une protéine il faut plusieurs mois de
travail à une équipe entière du
biochimiste Google avec alphago
alphafold l'été dernier a déterminé
enfin l'été 2022 a déterminé la
structure en trois dimension de 200
millions de protéines c'est un boulot
qui aurait pris à toute la communauté
biochimique mi 5000 ans Google l'a fait
en quelques semaines pendant l'été 2022
derrière on va faire avancer grâce à
l'intelligence artificiel de Google on
va faire avancer l'agrochochimie on va
faire avancer la médecine on va faire
avancer la lutte contre les maladies
dégénératives contre le cancer tu vois
le potentiel de l'intelligence
artificielle il est pas d'aider les gens
à mourir il est d'empêcher les gens de
mourir c'est c'est très intéressant mais
pour aller où et vers quoi qu'est-ce qui
va déterminer ça c'est le politique
c'est le peuple ou c'est l'intelligence
artificielle l'intelligence artificielle
n'a pas d'agenda elle n'a pas
d'agentivity comme disent les
Anglo-Saxons donc c'est soit les géants
de l'intelligence
artificielle soit la société par les
élections soit les
politiques à court terme ce ne sera pas
l'a dans un à plus long terme lia
peut-être Auton mais c'est ce qu'on
appelle forte mais ça n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui donc le débat politique doit
commencer il n'a pas commencé nick
bstrom qui est l'un des meilleur
spécialiste de la super intelligence
d'ailleurs s'est lamenté récemment en
disant ça fait 30 ans qu'on sait que
l'intelligence artificielle va
balayer et et va va déferler et on n'a
pas commencé à réfléchir on a perdu 30
ans ça fait 30 ans qu'on aurait dû
préparer la société civile préparer les
citoyens préparer les nos GAM main euh à
ce tsunami technologique et on l'a pas
fait donc aujourd'hui il n'est il n'est
que temps de s'y préparer euh on sait
que ça va être très difficile notamment
parce que l'éducation est une
technologie qui ne fonctionne pas c'est
très dur à dire et la réalité en 2023
c'est que
l'intelligence n'est pas magifiée par
l'école et que l'école n'a jamais
démontrer sa capacité à réduire les
inégalités intellectuelles c'est
horrible mais c'est la réalité de toute
façon ah bah
si l'école savait réduire les inégalités
intellectuelles il n'y aurait plus
d'inégalité
intellectuelle c'est bien parce que
l'école a très peu d'impact sur les
inégalités intellectuelles qu'il reste
des inégalités intellectuelles or les
inégalités intellectuelles elles sont
absolument majeures quel est le
pourcentage de la population qui est
capable de comprendre comment fonctionne
gpt4 1 milliè quel est est le
pourcentage de la population qui est
capable de
comprendre les équations d'un trou noir
1 milliè millionième quel est le
pourcentage de la population qui est
capable de comprendre les équations sur
le besoin de x 1 mliè on voit bien qu'il
n'y a pas d'égalité cognitive il y a des
gens qui comprennent des concepts très
compliqués d'autres qui les comprennent
moins il y a des gens très innovants des
gens moins innovant l'école c'est une
constatation que tout le monde peut
faire elle n'arrive pas à réduire ces
inégalités intellectuelles qui sont de
plus en plus graves au fur et à mesure
qu'on rondre dans dans un monde très
complexe et dans un monde où
l'intelligence artificielle galopee dans
un monde très simple en 1800 peu
technologique sans intelligence
artificielle les inégalités
intellectuelles étaient moins injustes
étaient moins problématiques dans le
monde de 2050 les inégalités
intellectuelles elles deviennent très
compliquées très problématiques parce
que elles font que les gens moins moins
doué moins innovant moins intelligents
ont du mal à comprendre la complexité du
monde et vont avoir du mal à trouver un
boulot et une utilité sociale face à
l'intelligence artificielle et l'école
et le monde politique n'a pas commencé à
réfléchir à ce grave problème on imagine
qu'en changeant deux trois broutis dans
le système éducatif on va rendre la
totalité de la
population complémentaire de
l'intelligence artificielle et capable
de galoper derrière les successeur de
gpt4 ce qui est totalement con et
totalement
délirant religion et intelligence
artificielle est-ce que l'intelligence
artificielle c'est devenu la nouvelle
canne numérique le le le nouvel
artifice pour faire maintenir une
société qui a perdu du sens perdu du Cap
est-ce que c'est pas devenu une nouvelle
religion il est clair qu'un nouveau dieu
va arriver c'est au odus c'est nous
c'est nous devenus dieux devenus démur
je par le potentiel de l'intelligence
artificielle et des technologies NBIC
les nanobiotechnologie l'informatique et
et les sciences du cerveau comment ça va
se structurer comment cette nouvelle
étape
théologique avec l'arrivée de l'homme
Dieu va structurer la société je ne sais
pas je pense que ça va être un peu
violent parce qu'il y a des gens très
conservateurs qui vont être profondément
choqués par cette invention
transhumaniste qui'est au us pour
reprendre l'expression d'arari mais moi
je pense que à la vitesse où galope
l'intelligence artificielle aujourd'hui
je pense que le transhumanisme va être
une étape très temporaire en réalité et
je m'en désole je pense qu'on va passer
à la posthumanité assez rapidement
transfert de conscience je pense que
nous allons abandonner notre corps parce
que notre cerveau biologique ne va pas
pouvoir galoper derrière l'intelligence
artificielle j'ai écrit
dans dans la guerre des intelligences à
l'heure de chatgpt il faut sauver le
GUID Michelin il faut sauver notre corps
il faut que nous
gardions une enveloppe une enveloppe
physique faut sauver le sexe faut sauver
la bouffe il faut garder un corps et il
faut devenir des transhumains
c'est-à-dire des hommes augmentés par la
technologie mais pas des posthumains
c'est des hommes qui ont abandonné leur
corps pour devenir en fait des
intelligences
artificielles mais je commence à ne plus
y croire et je commence à me demander si
on va pas passer rapidement à la à la
case posthumain en restant très peu de
temps à la case Transhumain comme
l'Allemagne de l'Est quand le mur est
tombé et resté une Allemagne de l'Est
autonome très très peu de temps avant de
tomber dans l'escarcelle de de
l'Allemagne de
l'Ouest ça ça m'angoisse un peu j'aurais
préféré que les transhumains gagnent à
la place des post humains j'aurais
préféré imaginer que le corps humain
perdure dans le fut cure et et au au
lieu d'une posthanité qui est un petit
peu anxiogène pour moi même si la
technologie en général me fascine plus
qu'elle ne m'angoisse ça ouvre quand
même des des des perspectives
gigantesques d'explorer le cosmos de
s'affranchir du
temps c'est notre problème si nous
voulons coloniser le
cosmos le corps est un vrai problème que
faire si on veut circuler à très grande
distance dans
l'univers pour aller à vitesse de la
lumière une intelligence artificielle
dématérialisée le peu et elle n'a pas de
sens du temps alors que nous il faudrait
nos criugénisé pendant des milliards
d'années c'est très très compliqué si on
veut aller à 1 milliard d'années lumière
ce qui est tout petit à l'échelle hein
du du cosmos hein une intelligence
artificielle va mettre un milliard
d'années une intelligence biologique
cryogénisée mettrait plusieurs milliards
d'années si elle se rapproche de la
vitesse de de la
lumière quel sens ça a pour un cerveau
biologique de voyager cryogénisé pendant
3 ou 4 milliards d'années aucun sens
donc la supériorité de l'intelligence
artificielle par rapport à
l'intelligence biologique est très forte
par
ailleurs notre cerveau est un outil
magnifique mais nos neurones ne peuvent
pas être beaucoup optimisés ils peuvent
l'être un petit peu mais la circulation
de l'information notre cerveau est très
lente autour d'un m par seconde à peu
près euh alors que euh dans
l'intelligence artificielle elle circule
à la vitesse de la lumière c'est-à-dire
300000 km à la seconde c'est-à-dire 300
millions de fois plus vite que la
circulation dans notre
cerveau on rembobine on accélère on
parlait de régulation réglementation à
l'heure actuelle nous sommes en guerre
une guerre non déclarée mais nous sommes
en guerre euh là je croyais que tu
parlais de l'Ukraine oui on parle de
l'Ukraine ah oui elle est déclarée oui
mais on on n pas consulté le Parlement
en France ah tu parles pour la France
oui c'estàd que nous officiellement nous
ne sommes pas en guerre contre la Russie
non non nous sommes pas en guerre nous
aidons un pays qui est en guerre qui est
l'Ukraine oui nous aidons un pays frère
et quand on voit
ça réguler de l'intelligence
artificielle dans un monde en guerre où
les ressources se se réduisent comme pot
de chagrin où la démographie nous emmène
sur euh euh une exponentielle ou des
pays pauvres vont être exposés au
réchauffement climatique ou on se
retrouve avec des pays agressifs les uns
les autres tu tu as dû remarquer qu'on
est loin de se faire des bisous sur la
bouche partout dans le monde à avancer
ensemble à essayer de se trouver une
porte de sortie
commune qu'est-ce que ça peut donner un
monde agressif qui développe des
intelligences artificielles agressives
intelligence artificielle plus
testostérone égal boom
ustrogène non parce que il y a peu de
femmes qui font la guerre à part madame
toucher pour reprendre la
chanson de Renault donc non le vrai
problème c'est intelligence artificielle
plus cerveau reptilien plus testostérone
bah tu sais comme comme je l'ai écrit
dans la guardre des
intelligences ma conviction c'est que
homodéus doit inventer un théologiciel
nous devons devons inventer un
catéchisme pour l'homme Dieu l'homme des
murges que nous sommes devenus parce que
utilise
catéchisme nous devons
euh gérer notre pouvoir
desmurgique et notre rapport au nouveau
dieu que nous sommes devenus parce que
nous avons un pouvoir limité nous
n'avons plus de limite il va bien
falloir encadrer notre Briss si nous ne
voulons pas être suicidaire d'ailleurs
on retombe sur le vieux paradoxe de
fermie pourquoi alors qu'il y a
au moins 2000 milliards de galaxies dans
l'Univers avec en moyenne 200 milliards
d'étoiles par galaxie et qu'il devrait y
avoir beaucoup de planètes abritant la
vie nous n'enregistront aucun signal B
la réponse est simple et non il y a
plusieurs réponses la première réponse
c'est qu'ils se cachent et qu'ils
n'émettent pas d'ondde la deuxième
réponse c'est que ils ne sont
pas suffisamment intelligents pour
communiquer les alienses la troisième
c'est qu'on ne sait pas bien écouter les
signaux qui viennent de très très loin
puis la 4ème hypothèse qui a été évoqué
dès les années 60 70 la 4e hypothèse
c'est que une civilisation quand elle
invente le transistor à une durée de vie
courte parce que elle crée des
intelligences artificielles et qu'elle
se
suicide par par
ubris est-ce que nous ne risquons pas ce
destin
qui explique peut-être le paradoxe de
Fermi que pour l'instant nous semblons
être la seule vie intelligente dans cet
univers absolument gigantesque est-ce
que les
civilisations arrivent à survivre le
jour où elles inventent des
intelligences artificielles le jour où
elles inventent le transistor ou ou son
équivalent je pense qu'il faut y
réfléchir à ce paradoxe de fermie et je
pense qu'il est urgent d'inventer le
théologiciel le le logiciel du Dieu que
nous devenons tu as peut-être oublié
une perception qui les petits hommes
verts nous regardent peut-être puis on a
l'air tellement trop con et trop
agressif que ils préfèrent pas rentrer
ouais je pense qu'ils émettraient quand
même des ondes il il faut pas oublier
que notre système solaire est très jeune
he notre système solaire est arrivé à à
peu près 9 milliards d'années après
après le Big Bang et et donc il y a eu
plein de systèmes solaires qui ont
existé des milliards d'années avant
notre système solaire donc il de devrait
y avoir des civilisations très avancées
qui devrai émettre beaucoup d'ondes dans
dans l'univers et on devrait les
recevoir même ces civilisations sont
très lointaines parce que elles auraient
dû exister des milliards d'années avant
avant avant nous-même or nous ne
recevons pas c'est quand même très très
très troublant tu as connu le projet
SETI oui qui qui qui n'est pas parfait
mais qui montre en tout cas que il y a
pas des masses de civilisations qui
envoient des ondes électromagnétiques
dans
l'univers pour revenir pour revenir
parce qu'on a parce qu'on a aujourd'hui
alors même que le City marche pas trop
mal on a quand même entendu aucune Honde
venant des aliens quand quand on voit
euh cette intelligence artificielle dans
un monde dangereux dans un monde stressé
dans un monde
agressif qu'est-ce qui se passe si une
intelligence artificielle décide
d'attaquer comme Skynet mais il faudrait
que l'intelligence artificielle a un
projet propre tu peux utiliser une
intelligence artificielle de type gpt4
et la manipuler pour qu'elle soit
agressive mais elle pas agressive de son
de son fait
propreenir oui oui je vois très bien
mais mon opinion n'est pas faite sur le
fait de savoir si on peut rapidement
avoir une intelligence artificielle
ayant une conscience artificielle et
ayant des objectifs
propres et il n'y a aucun consensus moi
je suis un un honnête homme de
l'intelligence artificielle je ne suis
pas un
développeur les développeurs les
spécialistes de l'intelligence
artificielle eux-mêmes les concepteurs
d'intelligigenence artificielle non'ont
n'ont aujourd'hui aucun consensus sur ce
sujet il n'y a pas de consensus sur le
fait de savoir s'il y a peut avoir une
conscience et un objectif
propre et on voit bien que il y a deux
types de danger avec l'intelligence
artificielle il y a la mauvaise
utilisation par l'intelligence
artificielle si elle n'a pas de
conscience et si elle est utilisée par
des méchants et puis il y a les dangers
lié à l'intelligence artificielle si
elle devenait consciente le premier
danger il est
évident les méchants peuvent utiliser
l'intelligence artificielle pour hacker
les missiles nucléairees du voisin pour
casser
euh pour pour casser les hôpitaux pour
hacker les hôpitaux pour hacker les pace
makakers on a démontré que c'était pas
très compliqué à faire ça ça existe
aujourd'hui en revanche l'intelligence
artificielle méchante qui aurait une
conscience artificielle et qui se
mettrait à attaquer l'homme pour
l'instant c'est une possibilité
théorique euh on est loin d'être face à
une réalité même si un papier
récent confirmait que d'un point de vue
mathématique on ne peut pas exclure
qu'une intelligence artificielle
consciente d'elle-même arrive dans le
futur est-ce qu'il faut interdire à
certains pays le le déploiement de
d'intelligence artificielle comme on a
pu le faire avec les armes nucléaires on
narrive pas à empêcher la Corée du Nord
de nous
narguer tous les 4 matins avec ses
missiles nucléaires on n'a pas empêché
Poutine de faire des bisous à au au
dictateur coréen du Nord et d'expliquer
que c'est un homme absolument
extraordinaire on voit mal comment à
l'ONU au sein du Conseil de sécurité on
pourrait bloquer les alliés de la Russie
d'acquérir la bombe atomique la Russie
est un allié proche aujourd'hui de deux
pays qui volent l'armatomique l'Iran et
la Corée du Nord euh la Corée du Nord a
déjà l'ARM atomique oui elle n'a pas
elle n'est pas elle n pas une arme
atomique totalement opérationnelle et
totalement moderne elle n'a pas des
missile probablement capable de résister
au au système antimissile américain
compris tu as pas compris en fait par
exemple
donc on n arrive pas on narrive pas à
empêcher la prolifération nucléaire
j'imagine mal qu'on puisse aller voir
les Chinois en leur expliquant qu'il
faut arrêter leur programme de recherche
en intelligence artificielle j'ouvre une
parenthèse tu n'a pas compris pourquoi
Kim ilsung Kim Jun a déployé une arme
nucléaire l'arme nucléaire nord-coréenne
c'est une arme de dissuasion à l'échelle
mondiale c'està-dire t leur test de
faire passer des missiles auudessus du
Japon près des bases américaines c'est à
mon sens de l'intox j'avais une grande
discussion avec le fondateur du
programme spatial français Jacques
BLAMON sur ce ce niveaul et il me
racontait que le leader nord-coréen veut
simplement faire ce que les Américains
leur ont fait en 1960 je demande à être
checker sur la date c'est-à-dire faire
décoller un missile à la verticale de
leur pays le faire péter dans une couche
haute de l'atmosphère ce qui charge
l'intégralité de l'atmosphère en
électricité et ça crame tout à l'époque
quand les Américains ont fait ça
pour magétique c'est ça à l'époque ça
avait cramé tous les satellites il y en
avait six là ça change la donne
c'est-à-dire que la Corée du Nord est
capable de faire passer l'intégralité de
la planète à l'âge de
pierre parenthèse
fermée si mes souvenirs sont mon c'était
solar fish on vous retrouvera le
nom question qui n'est pas
d'internet tu parlais de la faiblesse de
l'école et l'intelligence artificielle
peut-elle améliorer et l'enseignement et
il y a un autre mot ou pas non peut-êt
améliorer l'enseignement l'intelligence
artificielle peut très probablement
améliorer l'enseignement améliorer le
professeur mais attention attention au
fétichisme
technologique depuis 1980 la puissance
informatique à l'éducation nationale a
été multiplié par un million de
milliards vous pouvez faire le compte 1
million de
milliards est-ce que l'intelligence des
enfants a été multiplié par un million
de milliards non est-ce que la culture
des enfants a été multipliée par un
million de milliards est-ce que la le
taux de faute a été divisé par un
million de milliards non le niveau des
gamins n'a pas monté et beaucoup de
mauvaises langues prétendent même que le
niveau a baissé donc on a une explosion
de la puissance informatique à
l'éducation nationale sans effet sur le
niveau de nos
gamins on a pu démontrer que le
fétichisme technologique a fait penser
qu'on allait créer une génération de
Digital Natives qui allait apprendre
tout seul avec des iPad à l'école
l'impact des iPads l'impact des
ordinateurs à l'école est nul sur le
niveau des enfants je suis favorable à
ce qu' a des iPad et des ordinateurs à
l'école et mes enfants utilisent ces
outils librement mais ça n'a pas
d'impact sur le niveau des enfants il
faut que nos enfants sachent les
utiliser parce que ces outils sont
présent partout dans la société mais pas
avec l'illusion que les enfants vont
êtes plus intelligents et plus cultiver
grâce àoutil ça n'est pas le cas
l'électronique n'augmente pas le niveau
des enfants donc on a cru qu'on allait
résoudre le problème de l'école grâce à
la technologie c'est totalement
illusoire les iPads pour tous ça n'a pas
d'impact sur le niveau des enfants ce
fétichisme technologique qui s'est
poursuivi en imaginant qu'on allait
rendre tous les enfants codeur
informatique ce qui est complètement
stupide quand on sait à quel point c'est
compliqué de coder notamment à l'air de
de chat GPT
donc en réité il faut qu'on ait un
constat lucide sur l'école on demande
beaucoup à l'école et l'école a un
potentiel qui est limité pour une raison
tabou que tu connais nous en avons déjà
discuté c'est une raison horrible que la
société n'accepte pas c'est que
l'intelligence est majoritairement
génétique nos capacités intellectuelles
sont majoritairement
génétiques nos capacités de lecture sont
majoritairement génétiques plomine a
très bien montré dans des études très
très bien documentées que 64 % dans nos
différences de compréhension de ce que
nous lisons et dans nos capacités de
lecture sont d'origine génétique quand
un gamin ne lit pas bien c'est pas parce
que l'instituteur est connard c'est pas
parce que le gamin est paresseux c'est
d'abord pour des raisons génétiques il y
a là une énorme inégalité et aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas de technologie pour
réduire ces inégalités neurogénétiques
alors tes auditeurs vont se dire mais si
c'est génétique il y a rien à faire il
vont surtout dire que tu prêches le
dgénisme non c'est pas parce que quelque
chose est génétique qu'il faut s'asseoir
par terre et pleurer la mucovicidose est
une maladie 100 % génétique estce que la
connerie stup atts juste un mot la
mucovicidose est une maladie S pour
génétique elle tuait les jeunes Français
les jeunes Européens les jeunes
Américains entre 3 et 5 ans en 190 50
l'espérance de vie des mucovicidosiens
était
dramatique puis avec la technologie
médicale et maintenant grâce à des
technologies génétiques extrêmement
sophistiqué très coûteuse mais très
sophistiqué l'espérance de vie des
mucovicidosiens est en train d'atteindre
65 70 ans en 2035 l'espérance de vie en
France des gens qui ont les mucovicidos
sera la même que l'espérance de vie des
gens qui n'ont pas la
mucovicidose c'est une maladie 100 %
génétique
le déterminisme génétique est total et
la médecine la science ont cassé ce
déterminisme génétique jusqu'à permettre
une espérance de vie équivalente aux
gens qui n'ont pas cette maladie on peut
faire la même chose en en éducation dans
le futur d'ailleurs c'est le but de
l'éducation du futur c'est de casser le
déterminisme neurogénétique donc mon
discours n'est pas de dire les
inégalités intellectuelles sont
principalement d'origine génétique
acceptons des différences énormes et ne
nous battons pas mon discours est juste
l'inverse je dis le déterminisme
neurogénétique il est très fort dans les
différences de performance
intellectuelle des gamins et nous devons
faire comme en médecine nous devons
casser ce déterminisme neurogénétique
pour diminuer les inégalités
intellectuelles
faisons avec les enfants qui ont une
intelligence moins bonne qui ont une
cognition moins bonne diff différente
non moins bonne qui ont des capacités de
lecture moins bonnes faisons ce que nous
avons fait avec les enfants qui avaient
une mucovicidose depuis 50 ans cassons
ce déterminisme neurogénétique c'est de
mon point de vue la principale
responsabilité des politiques dans les
décennies qui viennent de casser le
déterminisme génétique de l'intelligence
pour diminuer les inégalités
intellectuelles et pour permettre à tout
le monde d'être compétitif face à
l'intelligence artificielle d'une part
et d'autre part de comprendre un monde
qui va être de plus en plus compliqué et
qui va être très très difficile à
comprendre pour les gens qui ont des
capacités conceptuelles plus
faibles tu comprends pourquoi ça choque
ça nous ne pouvons plus rester dans le
dénis l'intelligence artificielle
galopeppe très vite qu'il faut
moderniser d'urgence l'école et donc
nous ne pouvons plus nous mentir à
nous-mêm sur les raisons qui expliquent
les inégalité intellectuelle sinon nous
allons vers une catastrophe éducative
vers une catastrophe politique et une
catastrophe sociale le déni des
différences intellectuelles dans la
société était possible en 1950 il n'est
plus possible à l'air de l'intelligence
artificielle il est suicidaire nous
devons monitorer les différences
intellectuelles comprendre leur raisons
et les combattre pour éviter une
catastrophe sociale et politique
combattre avec bienveillance et et
beaucoup de technologie c'est pas avec
la gentillesse des enseignants qu'on va
casser les
déterminismes neurogénétiques disons-le
crument et c'est vraiment ce que je
pense quand tu un gamin pas très doué
qui a pas beaucoup de mémoire qui a du
mal à lire c'est pas avec un gentil
instituteur qui va comprendre la
physique quantique quand tu as un gamin
gentil et pas très bon et pas très
imaginatif c'est pas avec un gentil
instituteur qui va comprendre comment
fonctionne une blockchain donc il faut
sortir du du dénis ce n'est pas avec de
l'empathie et des gentils instituteurs
que les gens les moins doués vont
comprendre le monde de demain qui va
être extraordinairement complexe
d'ailleurs il est assez amusant de voir
que nos énormes différences de capacité
mnésique ne sont pas
tabou nous acceptons de dire qu'il y a
des gens qui ont énormément de mal à
retenir une poésie de trois lignes et
qu'il y a des gens qui arrivve à retenir
des milliers de pages ça ne choque
personne les différences cognitives
sur la mémoire ne choque personne tout
le monde admet qu'il y a des différences
gigantesques de capacité de
mémorisation en revanche les différences
de capacité à traiter l'information à
trier l'information c'est l'intelligence
là on est en complète àout il y a là
pour la sch pour la société un côté un
peu schizophrène pourquoi accepter la
réalité de l'énorme différence de
capacité de mémorisation et pourquoi
refuser les énormes différen de capacité
intellectuelle de capacité de tri et
d'analyse des données c'est quelque
chose de très
curieux je vais me faire l'avocat du
diable le milieu socioc-culturel d'un
gamin il a un impact assez faible je
suis pas du tout d'accord mais tu as
tort tu ne connais pas les études si tu
regardes les études tu te rends compte
tu te rendrais compte que les quelles
sont les études ah bah plumine a fait
des études géantes en ayant toutes les
statistiques anglaises qui lu ont été
données à à partir de 95 96 et on s'est
rendu compte que la part du milieu est
minoritaire dans nos capacités
intellectuelles on on s'est au départ
Tromp parce que il y a une corrélation
qui a notamment été très bien étudiée
par Robert plomine hein qui est le
spécialiste mondial de la génétique de
l'intelligence il y a une corrélation
très forte entre le nombre de livres
dans une maison et le niveau
intellectuel des enfants et et la
capacité de bien lire des enfants et
donc les gens on dit regardez c'est
culturel quand il y a des livres à la
maison les gens sont les gamins sont
intelligents et ils lisent bien c'est
bien culturel l'intelligence sauf que
plumine s'est rendu compte à son grand
étonnement que cette corrélation
n'existait pas pour les enfants
adoptés c'est pas le fait qu'il y a des
livres dans une maison qui fait que les
enfants sont en moyenne intelligents
c'est qu'en fait les maisons dans
lesquelles il y a beaucoup de livres
sont des maisons où les gens sont
intelligent on un bon patrimoine
neurogénétique et l'ont transmis à nos
enfants à leurs enfants et on s'est
trompé on a confondu corrélation et
causalité et on a très longtemps fait
des erreurs méthodologiques très
importantes qui ont conduit à penser que
l'intelligence était principalement lié
au milieu alors qu'elle est
principalement liée à la génétique il y
a une autre raison méthodologique à la
base de cette erreur c'est que
l'héritabilité de l'intelligence elle
croit avec l'âge al j'ouvre une
parenthèse il y a il y a une histoire de
gène récessif autosomal ou pas du tout
ça a été étudié c'est multigénique c'est
dire que il y a pas un gène de
l'intelligence ça dire quoi récessif
autosomal on va pas se lancer dans une
explication autosomal ça veut dire les
chromosomes non sexuels et récessif ça
veut dire que ça n'est pas un gène
dominant contrairement à aux gènes
dominant qui eux sont s'expriment même
quand ils ne sont
qu'à que sur un seul chromosome mais
pour revenir à not s'exprime est-ce que
le milieu
extérieur joue quand même sur le le
l'expression de ce gêne le milieu joue
sur l'expression et compris sur le plan
intellectuel l'intellectuel
l'intelligence n'est pas 100 % génétique
je n'ai absolument pas dit ça je n'ai
jamais prétendu que l'intelligence est
100 % génétique si je prends un marteau
et que je te tape sur la tête et que je
te et que je te donne une écout écoute
une seconde si je prends un marteau et
que je te tape sur la tête et que je te
fais une hémorragie cérébrale tu vas
être neux et ce sera pas génétique ce
sera bien lié à l'environnement donc je
n'ai pas prêt une comotion je seraiis
pas neux je oui tu seras neneux si tu
fais une grave hémorragie cérébrale tu
vas être neneux si tu ne meurs pas donc
l'intelligence est majoritairement
génétique mais pas totalement j'ai pas
dit que l'école avait un rôle nul j'ai
pas dit que l'environnement n'avait pas
nul j'ai dit un rôle un rôle minoritaire
mais l'autre raison pour laquelle on
s'est trompé sur l'héritabilité de
l'intelligence c'est qu'on a regardé les
enf enfants quand ils étaient petits
notamment les enfants adoptés quand ils
étaient petits or
l'intelligence des enfants est davantage
lié au milieu quand ils sont petits et
davantage lié à la génétique quand ils
grandissent autrement dit un enfant
adopté à à peu près le CA intellectuel
des enfants qui l'ont adopté quand il a
3 4 ans et à 18 ans il a le Coch
intellectuel des parents biologiques
des
grands-parents là on parle des des
parents donc on a regarder
l'intelligence des enfants adoptés quand
ils étaient petits et pas quand ils
étaient grands et on n'a pas réalisé ce
problème qui est que l'intelligence
pendant l'enfance est de plus en plus
génétique et de moins en moins lié au
milieu et pour ce qui concerne les
enfants adoptifs en moyenne les enfants
adoptifs ont des difficultés à l'école
il y a des exceptions bien sûr mais en
moyenne les enfants de petits font des
difficultés à l'école parce que il est
rare que des grands intellectuels
abandonnent leur enfant à la naissance
et donc en moyenne les gens qui
je l'ai vu quand j'étais étudiant en
médecine des des les parents qui qui
abandonnent leur enfant la naissance en
général ce ne sont pas des intellectuels
ce sont des gens qui ont des difficultés
intellectuelles sociales très
importantes et en moyenne les enfants
qui sont sur le marché de l'adoption
sont des enfants qui vont avoir des
difficultés intellectuelles parce qu'ils
viennent de famille avec des grandes
difficultés intellectuelles
personnellement je n'ai encore jamais vu
des intellectuels euh polytechniciens
plus Harvard abandonnés à la maternité
leur enfant après l'accouchement il y a
là un déterminisme social très important
les enfants adoptés sont quasi
exclusivement des enfants qui viennent
de milieu ayant de grandes difficultés
intellectuelles et ça se traduit sur le
Nau niveau des enfants qui ont été
adoptés quand ils arrivent à
l'adolescence est-ce qu'on peut être
très intelligent est un sacré connard
oui j'avais écrit un un papier dans
l'Express les nazis le C intellectuel et
la
bonté quand il y a eu
nurberg les Américains et notamment
l'équipe de psychologues et de médecins
qui expertisaient les bourreaux nazis et
dont beaucoup étaient juifs pensaient
que les bourreaux nazis étaient des
abrutis pas bien compris les bourreaux
naziis étai étaai des
abrutis beaucoup étai juif j'ai mal
entendu qui ont expertisé les bourreaux
nazis l'équipe de médecins et de
psychologu qui ont expertisé les
bourreaux nazis avant le procès de
nurberg était juif et donc ils
imaginaient légitimement que les
bourreaux nazis étaient étaient des
crétins et ils ont été extrêmement
surpris de voir le C intellectuel élevé
de la plupart des bourreaux nazis qui
étaient des salots sans
cœur mais qui était très intelligent il
n'y a pas de corrélation entre à la
bonté et et et l'intelligence c'est ce
que je voulais expliquer dans cet
article de L'Express et je confirme euh
notre intelligence n'est pas prédictive
de nos capacités morales il faut séparer
les deux dossiers mais dans la société
de demain je défie quiconque de
m'expliquer que face à l'intelligence
artificielle il vaudra mieux être sans
imagination sans mémoire et et peu
intelligent pour être compétitif et pour
s'en sortir je pense vraiment le
contraire je pense que le monde de
demain sera l'âge d'or des gens les plus
innovants et les plus intelligents et
sera et sera un monde compliqué pour les
gens moins innovant et et et moins malin
même si une fois encore je le répète ce
sujet est complètement tabou à tort
parce que ça nous empêche de piloter la
révolution cognitive qui arrive et ça
nous promet beaucoup de malheur parce
que je vois dans les années qui viennent
j'imagine que que beaucoup de gens vont
avoir du mal à suivre le rythme effrainé
mené par la société de de la
connaissance par le capitalisme cognitif
ti fais voir la couverture de ton
bouquin ça va réveiller le
caméraman est-ce que dans ton bouquin je
le sais d'ailleurs ça parle de de
chinois ou de pays émergents où on leur
propose la sélection
d'ambron alors la sélection d'ambrion
comme tu sais on en fait déjà 96 % des
enfants
trisomiques sont avortés en Europe c'est
de la sélection embryonnaire c'est de
l'ugénisme négatif c'est détruit un
futur bébé parce qu'il a des qualités
qu'on ne veut pas des caractéristiques
qu'on ne veut pas mais c'est déjà de la
sélection embryonnaire alors la question
de la sélection embryonnaire qu'on
appelle le génisme positif cette fois-ci
ser sélectionné des critères que l'on
souhaite des critères positifs elle est
aujourd'hui très marginale et elle n'est
pas encouragée ni par le corps médical
ni par l'État ni par les sociétés
d'analysees génétique et d'ailleurs aux
États-Unis un test génétique qui
permettait de mesurer les
caractéristiques de l'embryon formé lors
des fécondations in vitro permettait
aussi de mesurer de de de de de
découvrir certaines caractéristiques
intellectuelles euh du futur bébé et le
patron le patron de la boîte de
génétique a décidé de ne pas révéler aux
parents les caractéristiques
intellectuelles prévisibles de euh de
l'embron en éprouvette sauf en cas de
handicap il considère qu'il est licite
pour lui société d'analyse génétique de
dire aux parents votre bébé va avoir une
maladie et va avoir un handicap
intellectuel en revanche il considère
qu'il n'est pas licite pour lui de dire
écoutez cet embryon là va être plus
intelligent que celui-là donc je vous
conseille de prendre l'embryon A14
plutôt que l'embryon
B12 on voit qu'il y a là un débat
éthique qui a commencé alors même qu'il
est possible de repérer en en éprouvette
lors de la fécondation invitro de
repérer des futurs bébés qui risque
d'avoir des capacités intellectuelles
supérieures tu prends des
vitamines non je ne prends pas de
vitamines et les études sur les
vitamines et les compléments
alimentaires montre qu'ils réduisent
l'espérance de vie et comme je suis un
fanatique de la médecine basé sur les
preuves et sur les essais cliniques
randomisés je ne prends pas de
compléments alimentaires dont on a
démontré qu'ils sont nocifs même si les
gens se les arrachent dans les
pharmacies on revient on revient sur
l'amélioration grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle j'aimerais quand même
revenir sur c'est quoi l'intelligence
parce que apprendre des pages apprendre
des l'intelligence l'intelligence est
très simple Laurent Laurent laisse-moi
terminer si tu veux comprendre ma
question l'intelligence c'est très
simple pour toi mais est-ce que tu vas
juger un
tableau en fonction du cuit déjà le cuit
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire alors écoute
on va pas revenir sur ce débat le CUI le
CUI est le meilleur et le meilleur moyen
de mesurer l'intelligence de quelqu'un
pour le dire autrement le CUI est plus
pertinent pour mesurer l'intelligence de
quelqu'un que la taille de la
[__] tu es d'accord si je te donne si je
te donne pour quelqu'un la taille de la
[__] attends non mais écoute-moi si je
te si je te donne le cui si je te donne
le Qi et la taille de la [__] quel est
le critère que tu vas préférer pour
analyser l'intelligence de cette
personne le QI tu es d'accord oui bon tu
vois donc le QI a une certaine
pertinence
alors la réponse à ta question c'est
quoi l'intelligence c'est très simple
l'intelligence c'est ce qui permet de
prendre le
pouvoir c'est c'est très simple
l'intelligence c'est ce qui permet de
prendre le pouvoir pouvoir
financier pouvoir intellectuel pouvoir
entrepreneurial pouvoir religieux
pouvoir politique Mélenchon s'il est
quiil est c'est parce qu'il est plus
intelligent que les autres c'est pas
parce qu'il colle les affiches mieux que
les autres c'est pas le fait de coller
bien les affiches qui fait que tu prends
la tête du parti les colleurs d'affiches
à la France en soumise c'est pas les
chefs c'est les grouillau il y en a
aucun qui a le droit de l'ouvrir il y a
les mêm dans les autres partis il y a
les autres dans les mêmes parti
exactement Mélenchon c'est pas parce
qu'il il porte mieux le paquet de col
qu'il est à la tête de Alfi c'est parce
qu'il est très intelligent même si je
n'aime pas son idéologie donc quel que
soit le secteur dans lequel tu es
l'intelligence c'est ce qui permet de
prendre le pouvoir et comme nous sommes
dans le siècle de l'économie de la
connaissance du capitalisme cognitif
l'intelligence est encore plus
importante qu'elle était Jadice est-ce
que l'intelligence aussi c'est pas
survivre quand je vois l'évolution des
papillons quand je vois l'évolution des
virus et des
amibes c'est ça
survivre bien répondre à l'évolution au
contrainte darwinienne c'est une forme
d'intelligence biologique mais c'est pas
de l'intelligence conceptuelle
l'intelligence dont on dont on parle oui
le virus a une forme d'intelligence au
niveau au niveau
nanotechnologique qui fait qu'il arrive
à s'adapter aux contraintes darwiniennes
auxquell il est soumis mais il n'a pas
d'intelligence conceptuelle quand je
parle d'intelligence je parle
d'intelligence conceptuelle je ne parle
pas de l'intelligence d'E fourmillère un
mot sur ce que ce que certains appellent
le cauti
émotionnel tu escroquerie intellectuelle
pour vendre des bouquins pour les de
gauche c'est ça que non pour pour les
sociologues pour les mauvais sociologues
euh l'idée sur laquelle les cons sont
plus empathiques que les gens
intelligents est une idée totalement
fausse d'ailleurs si tu dois partir en
vacances tu vas partir avec quelqu'un
d'intelligent pas avec un con ce qui
prouve bien que les gens intelligents
sont
pas Mo empique que les cons si je devais
partir en vacances je partirai avec Eric
Sadin en Amérique du Sud ouais pourquoi
tu fais ouais
non parce que parce que Sadin est un
garçon rigolo et iconoclaste pas rigolo
mais mais mais mais je le trouve par
moment un peu fatiguant
pourquoi je trouve qu'il a une capacité
d'écoute des autres qui est limitée mais
comme on dirait un homme il n'écoute pas
les autres je suis pas d'accord avec toi
mais mais tu as le droit tu as le droit
tu me connais tu as le droit nous
pouvons être en désaccord alors
acceptons soyons d'accord sur ce
désaccord soyons en accord sur ce
désaccord la la l'endurcissement la
résilience de la technologie de
l'intelligence artificielle par exemple
je te donne deux facteurs l'intelligence
artificielle utilise le réseau
électrique l'intelligence artificielle
utilise des matières premières
l'intelligence artificielle sans énergie
est-ce que ça a été conceptualisé est-ce
que l'intelligence artificielle face à
une éruption solaire ça a été
conceptualisé est-ce que on n'est pas en
train de s'exposer à
une à une
humanité
fragile alors les réseaux électriques ne
sont pas on a on a une fragilité
technologique enfin la fragilité
qu'avaent nos
ancêtres
alasco pendant la dernière glaciation
hein quand tu te les gelais
et quand aller à la chat c'était une
épreuve et avec un effondrement
démographique qui a été mesuré récemment
et qui a été colossal il était plus
important les études génétiques à partir
des OSM anciens ont montré que la
population italienne pendant la dernière
glaciation est tombé à
zéro tous les gens de la bîte italienne
sont morts ils ont tous crevé il n'y a
plus
tragénétique de la population italienne
d'origine après la dernière ation alors
à l'époque il y avait pas d'italien je
te rassure j'ai dit les gens de la botte
italienne que j'appelle les
Italiens même si c'est un contresens
historique mais c'est plus simple pour
décrire la population dont dont je parle
donc quand Touré en
1348 et que 45 % de la population
européenne crève en 1000 jours de la
peste on est plus fragile qu'aujourd'hui
et je te rappelle qu'ils étaaiit pas
prêt d'avoir une solution face à la
peste parce que il a fallu attendre
exactement 600 ans après la grande peste
de 1348 pour avoir le premier anti
antibiotique contre la peste qui est la
tétracycline de pizer encore pizer donc
quand la grande peste est arrivée et a
tué plus de 4 européens sur 10 on était
à 6 siècles d'avoir un antibiotique
contre la peste en
1887 6 mois avant l'invention de l'ppind
disectomie de l'opération pour traiter
l'appendicite 100 % des gens qui avaient
une appendicite aigu crevaient ouais on
dit péritonite au lieu de dire crev il
crevait Napoléon I j'ai fait une litias
urinaire il y a pas longtemps euh
Napoléon I il est mort d'une lithas
urinaire à cause d'un calcul rénal il
est mort tout empereur qu' tout ancien
empereur qu'il était en 1873 alors même
que en exilant en Angleterre la reine
Victoria lui avait prêté son chirurgien
personnel dans les rues de Paris on
passait prendre les gamins morts pendant
la nuit de la diphérie qui est une forme
d' d'angine mortel jusqu'à l'invention
du vaccin contre les diftérie il y a un
peu plus de de 200 ans donc l'humanité
était extrêmement fragile je te rappelle
que l'espérance de vie à Paris en 1750
était de 25 ans pour les hommes 27 ans
par les pour les femmes avec une
mortalité très forte dans les premières
années quatre enfants sur 10 mourrait
avant
d'atteindre d'avant d'atteindre 5 6 ans
donc non dire que l'humanité est
aujourd'hui fragile parce que les
réseaux électriques peuvent craquer
c'est indécent par rapport à l'extrême
fragilité de l'humanité dans le passé
l'humanité a failli a failli disparaître
à plusieurs reprises une autre étude
génétique récente monondre qui a eu un
effondrement absolument catastrophique
de la population européenne il y a
environ 70000 de pardon de la population
mondiale il y a entre 70000 et 800 an
non l'humanité a a failli crever comme
néanderta l'a crevé à plusieurs reprises
nous sommes moins fragiles aujourd'hui
mais Néandertal n'a pas crevé nertal a
fusionné non Néandertal a partiellement
fusionné mais il a quand même
disparu on connaît d'ailleurs le le taux
de fécondité de Néandertal il était très
très très faible Néandertal s'est
effondré et il a il a effectivement un
petit peu il a copulé avec avec avec
nous Homo sapiens c'est la raison pour
lequelle on a à peu près on a à peu près
1,5 à 2,5 % d'ADN commun avec avec avec
N enfin d'ADN qui provient de de
Néandertal mais Néandertal est quand
même mort comme tous les autres hinidé
homoérectus
homoabilis et cetera on pourrait il y en
a il y en a il y en a plusieurs dizaines
donc nos ancêtres n'ont pas survécu
nous-même homo-apiens on a failli mourir
à plusieurs reprises on est beaucoup
beaucoup moins fragile aujourd'hui euh
que dans les plaines d'akitain pendant
la dernière glaciation je te le promets
tu as suivi les démissauviens chez les
Chinois non pas encore intéresse-toi à
ça c'est pas mal c'est extraordinaire
attends l'aventure des nisovienes qui
est une autre humanité qui a disparu il
y a à peu près 40000 ans est
extraordinaire et récemment on a on a
fait des tels progrès dans l'analyse ADN
que maintenant en
séquençant le sable la terre dans les
grottes on arrive à reconstituer l'arbre
généalogique sur des famille entière et
à retrouveré l'histoire c'est absolument
extraordinaire et et c'est un sujet
connexe en analysant un cimetière ancien
au sud de Paris on a analysé les osmans
et on a reconstitué les portrait robbot
parce que à partir de l'ADN de quelqu'un
on peut connaître la forme de son visage
on a reconstitué l'arbre généalogique
des gens qui étaient dans le cimetière
on a reconstitué les familles et on a
reconstitué les visages en par portrait
robot génétique c'est absolument
fascinant comment tu juges le niveau de
nos politiques le niveau intellectuel de
nos politiques alors je sais que tu es
un dévau d'Emmanuel
Macron comment tu juges le reste du
gouvernement écoute c'est très clair le
niveau de la classe politique est en
voie d'effondrement tout le monde le
sait le niveau des ministres quand
giscar était président éit
exceptionnellement élevé le niveau des
ministres le niveau des députés le
niveau des hommes politiques euh
souousmiteran était
exceptionnel on a découragé les gens de
faire de la politique les politiciens
sont accusés d'être corrompu ce qui
n'est pas vrai ils sont accusés d'être
des salots ce qui n'est pas vrai ils se
font engueuler toute la journée personne
leur dit merci ils sont accusés d'être
trop payés alors que quand tu fais de la
politique tu gagnes 10 fois 20 fois 100
fois moins que quand tu travailles dans
le secteur privé donc les politiques se
font chier toute la journée et il y en a
beaucoup qui craquent une partie
importante des politiciens les plus
intelligents ont abandonné la politique
parce qu'ils ne supporte plus qu'on leur
crache à la gueule alors même qu'il se
sacrifie tes auditeurs le savent
probablement dans le secteur privé on
gagne beaucoup d'argent quand on est
malin et qu'on travaille beaucoup si on
prend par exemple l'exemple de chat GPT
des LLM il y a pas un
seul très bon spécialiste de chat GPT et
de ses équivalents en France qui gagne
moins d'un million d'euros par an il y
en a pas un
seul dans le privé tu peux gagner
beaucoup d'argent en politique tu gagnes
pas beaucoup d'argent tu te fais
engueuler la population dit que que dit
des ores sur toi et ben les gens sont en
train de craquer il faut qu'on
réhabilite le politique le politique
fait des choses très compliquées il faut
qu'on protège les politiques contre les
agression il faut payer les politiques
davantage faut qu'il y ait moins de
députés mais beaucoup mieux payé il faut
que les ministres soient beaucoup mieux
payés il faut que les gens dans les
cabinets ministériels soient beaucoup
mieux payés pour avoir des bons parce
que les enux je absolument incroyable
dont on a parlé au cours de cette
émission vont nécessiter des des élites
politiques de très très haut niveau donc
il faut qu'il ait dans le secteur privé
des gens intelligents innovants malins
entreprenants mais il sonut il faut
aussi dans la sphère publique et dans la
sphère politique qu'on a des gens
ambitieux
malins innovants et pour ça il faut
qu'ils aient une vie vivoable en tant
que politicien il faut qu'il soit payé
correctement qu'il faut qu'il soit
estimé par la population et c'est pas le
chemin
comprend c'est un secret de polychidel
globalement le niveau de la classe
politique
s'effondre quand tu discutes avec des
députés tu es parfois consterné par leur
méconnaissance des dossiers tout parti
confondu hein tout parti confondu ça
n'était pas le cas en 1975 ou en 1980
donc oui il faut retrouver des élites
politiques capables de piloter
l'incroyable transformation sociétale à
laquelle on assiste et ça suppose qu'on
aime les politiques qu'on les respecte
euh qu'on leur crache pas à la gueule je
le répète et qu'on les paye plus oui
j'ouvre une parenthèse est-ce qu'on est
pas en train est-ce qu'on a pas déjà
sélectionné les plus cupides les plus
agressifs les plus Mégal non ils ils
sont pas cupides ils sont juste moins
bons dire que aujourd'hui une partie
importante des politiques font de la
politique parce
que ils peuvent pas faire autre chose
d'ailleurs pas mal pas mal de députés
quand ils arrêtent d'être députés
aujourd'hui n'arrivent pas à trouver un
taf respectable dans le secteur privé
parce que leur valeur marchande est très
faible dans le secteur privé dans la
sphère compétitive pour ça qu'il
s'accroche certains ouais
ouais est-ce est-ce est-ce qu'on est pas
en train de d'avoir des mégalow
légèrement
neunneux qui ont été sélectionnés parce
que ils sont capables d'intriguer ils
sont capables de
louvoyer ils sont capables de manipuler
si tu n'es pas un manipulateur si tu
n'es pas un
storyteller si tu n'es pas capable d'
intriguer tu prends pas le pouvoir donc
ça c'est une caractéristique de tous les
gens qui prennent le pouvoir dans le
secteur politique mais ça ça n'est pas
grave il faut des bons par définition un
politicien intrigue un peu sinon il
aurait pas pris le pouvoir le problème
c'est qu'il faut qu'il comprenne les
enjeux du monde qui vient et qu'il soit
malin pour adresser au nom de l'intérêt
général et de l'ensemble de la
population les enjeux incroyablement
compliqué qui qui se dessine aujourd'hui
on ouvre une parenthèse où je te pose de
trois questions d'Internet et puis vas-y
alors tu préfères quoi les question
Internet ou nou une parenthèse je c'est
toi le chef j'aime quand tu me parles
comme ça
euh le PK moyen a-t-il besoin de
comprendre la physique
quantique je le
pense moi je le scénario à la Métropolis
dans lequel juste une toute petite élite
comprend la complexité du monde me donne
la nausée donc je suis un méritocratique
qui pense que les élites doivent
partager la connaissance et la
compréhension du monde
je trouve que c'est nos vies sont
relativement courtes la mort de la mort
n'est pas encore arrivée je pense que
pendant nos vies courtes c'est plus
sympa de contrôler de comprendre le
monde donc de contrôler sa vie dans dans
dans l'hyper complexité qui vient et je
trouve que c'est triste d'être balloté
par les élites et de ne pas comprendre
le monde donc oui je pense que tout le
monde doit comprendre la physique
quantique que tout le monde doit
comprendre la blockchain même si son
potentiel industriel est beaucoup plus
faible que certains l'ont pensé je pense
que tout le monde le monde doit
comprendre comment fonctionne l'ADN je
pense que tout le monde doit être
capable de comprendre comment fonctionne
une thérapie génique je pense que tout
le monde doit comprendre comment le Big
Bang
s'est organisé je pense que tout le
monde doit être capable de comprendre ce
qu'est le le le vide quantique qui a
précédé le Big Bang dans l'hypothèse
acceptée par une partie significative
des astrophysiciens aujourd'hui oui la
proposition contraire qui est de
réserver la connaissance de la
complexité du monde à une petite élite
et ce n'est pas ce n'est pas ce que je
veux ce n'est pas ce que je souhaite
pour la société je te le répète ce monde
à la Métropolis me fait profondément
peur je suis pour le partage des
neurones je suis pour le partage de
l'intelligence je suis pour le partage
de la de la cognition de la
compréhension des choses question
internet qui ressemble encore un petit
peu mais on on va la poser quand même on
peut pas avoir un autre projet de vie
que la physique quantique et la
blockchain ben bien sûr que si moi je
passe 6 semaines par an au ski avec mes
gamins je suis un passionné de ski
j'adore le ski c'est pas de la physique
quantique mais j'adore et il n'y a pas
que la physique quantique mais je pense
que c'est mieux pour un citoyen au-delà
de ses dadas de ce qu'il aime en matière
artistique de ce qu'il aime faire avec
ses enfants je pense que c'est bien de
comprendre la science de comprendre le
monde en plus mais je ne vais pas moi
abandonner mes mais 6 semaines de ski
pour faire de la physique quantique on
est bien d'accord on va reparler des 6
semaines de ski d'ailleurs question
internet intéressant de points
n'avez-vous pas le sentiment de vous
contredire quand vous disiez que les
gens les moins intelligents occuper des
postes comme caissière femme de ménage
et cetera et cetera pointinrogation
alors que les enfants de ces personnesl
sont dans des milieux sociocculturels
défavorisés et ne se retrouvent pas dans
des milieux professionnels élevés à
cause de la production sociale défendu
par Bourdieu un mot dessus monsieur
Alexandre oui mais je ne je l'ai
expliqué Bourdieu a tort
et excusez-moi mais les études à
Polytechnique sont
gratuites on est même payé quand on est
à normalsp à lenat à Polytechnique on
est payé par l'État donc il y a pas de
problème de bourse les gens intelligents
peuvent se présenter au concours
d'entrée à Polytechnique quel que soit
leur milieu et de dire qu'il y a une
prve de reproduction sociale au sens de
pour Dieu c'est peut-être possible dans
les pays où les études supérieures sont
très chèes mais dans les pays comme la
France où les études sont quasi
gratuites voire totalement gratuite pour
les plus grandes écoles françaises et et
avec des études qui où on est payé pour
faire ces études l'argument bourdisien
il ne tient pas donc cette reproduction
sociale est un fantasme de Bourdieu et
je pense que Bourdieu d'ailleurs j'ai
fait plusieurs articles ces dernières
années expliquant que Bourdieu avait
totalement tort hélas j'aimerais bien
que pour Dieu a raison pourquoi ce
serait plus simple un monde dans lequel
l'ADN n'expliquerait pas nos différences
intellectuelles et dans lequel en
améliorant le niveau des instituteurs
tout le monde pour pourrait rentrer à
Harvard ou à normal supredulme ce serait
un monde beaucoup plus cool et qui
personnellement euh me sirait mieux mais
ça n'est pas la réalité et d'ailleurs si
c'était la réalité ça voudrait dire que
la faute de la reproduction
sociale elle est liée à l'école et aux
instituteurs et que les instituteurs du
93 ne sont pas bons ce qui n'est pas le
cas les instituteurs du 93 ils se
donnent beaucoup de mal mais ils ont du
mal à
faire à faire faire des grandes études
aux gamins qui ont un moins bon
patrimoine
neurogénétique la vision de Bourdieu
elle est en fait culpabilisante elle est
culpabilisante pour les parents et elle
est culpabilisante pour les enseignants
dans les zones
difficiles et je pense que ils ont tort
je ne crois pas que les instituteurs
soient moins bon dans le 93 qu' Neili
pourtant les enfants réussissent mieux
neu d'ailleurs j'ouvre une parenthèse
pensez à vous abonner à notre chaîne
YouTube en activant la petite cloche et
les notifications en priorité et et si
le cœur vous en dit soutenez-nous sur
tipi c'est grâce à vous qu'on peut
continuer question internet je suis
autiste j'ai un cuit très très élevé 4
écart type cela m'a pas rendu heureux
pour autant et en moyenne les autistes
thpi finissent mal alors première
chose le lien entre Cu bonheur il est
pas absolu mais les gens intelligents
sont plutôt plus heureux que les gens
moins
intelligents deuxièmement on a longtemps
dit que les gens très intelligents
étaient globalement malheureux et
étaient plus souvent chez le psychiatre
que les autres Franck Rasmus qui est le
grand spécialiste du sujet en France a
démontré que c'était totalement faux
c'est lié à un biais méthodologique
c'est que les enfants très intelligents
et bien dans leur pompe ne vont pas voir
le psychiatre et on teste pas leur cuit
il n'y a que les
enfants intelligents et malheureux et
déprimés qui vont chez le psychiatre et
qui ont un test de cui puisque le test
de cuit n'est pas généralisé en France
contrairement à des pays comme comme
Israël donc le psychiatre ne voit que
des surdoués malheureux il ne voit pas
la grande majorité des surdoués heureux
donc non les surdoués ils sont pas plus
malheureux que les moins doués ils sont
plutôt plus heureux il y a bien sûr des
groupes qui ont plus de difficultés les
aspergurs dont dont Monsieur fait partie
ont parfois des difficultés d'adaptation
ils ont un Q élevé mais ils ont parfois
des difficultés d'insertion et
d'adaptation mais c'est un cas
particulier personnellement sur le plan
de la dénomination j'aimerais qu'on
cesse d'appeler les gens qui ont un
asperger et qui ont 170 de cuit
comme certains des grands grand patron
de la silicone vallleé c'est le cas
notamment de Sam Altman le fondateur de
chat GPT qui a un as berger il a
lui-même déclaré dans une interview au
New Yorker j'aimerais qu'on arrête de
les appeler autist l'autiste c'est un
gamin en extrêmement grande difficulté
qui ne saura le plus souvent jamais
parler qui ne sera jamais scolarisé qui
ne sera jamais intégré c'est ça le vrai
autisme de mettre le mot autisme pour
les aspergurs qui font souvent des
carrières éblouissantes et qui sont
extrêmement
intelligents même s'ils ont quelques
petites difficultés relationnelles et d'
ertion c'est abusif il faut arrêter de
mettre autiste à toutes les sauces non
monsieur vous n'êtes pas autiste vous
avez un asperger vous êtes très
intelligent et vous pouvez avoir
quelques petites difficultés
professionnelles à cause des partic
particularité psychologique des autistes
mais vous allez trouver un chemin vous
allez trouver une niche écologique et
vous allez faire des choses grandioses
comme l'immense majorité des aspergurs à
très haut cuit dans la siliconevallée il
y en a plein Marc Zuckerberg beaucoup de
gens pensent qu'il a qu'il est asperger
euh comme Sam alttman qui a une carrière
absolument extraordinaire et qui fait
des choses magnifiques en tant
qu'inventeur de de chat GPT donc oui
l'intelligence ne rend pas toujours
heureux non les gens intelligents sont
pas plus malheureux que les gens moins
intelligents et trois euh je n'ai aucun
doute que vous allez faire des choses
magnifiques et et retirer de votre
cerveau le mot autiste vous êtes un
aspergur ce qui est tout euh euh sauf
une insulte parce que les Aspergers
étant en moyenne très intelligents ils
ont une contribution à la société qui
est en général formidable est-ce que tu
as vu le film Bienvenue à gatakia oui
bien
sûr il est un petit peu naïf parce que
c'est une vision de la génétique des
années 80 de la fin des années 90 quand
on pensait que nos caractéristiques
étaient liées à un seul gène on sait
aujourd'hui que ce qui fait notre notre
être et nos capacités intellectuelles
psychologiques ce sont c'est une chimie
une alchimie complexe entre plein de
parties d'autre ADN y compris ce qui
n'est pas les gènes mais qui sont les
zones régulatrices de l'ADN qui
représentent la quasi-ttalité de de
notre ADN puisque nos gènes ne
représentent qu'une petite partie de
l'ADN à peu près 50 millions de paires
de base sur 3 milliards donc bienvenue à
gataka et rigolo mais avec une vision
qui est une vision ancienne où notre ADN
explique de façon simple nos
caractéristiques alors que en réalité ce
que nous sommes est le fruit de
multiples parties de notre ADN et
d'interaction de notre ADN avec
l'environnement est-ce que les
intelligences artificielles sont en
train d'étudier nos
télomères il y a des gens qui
travaillent sur la télomas en utilisant
l'intelligence artificielle mais c'est
une voie assez compliquée parce que
quand on bloque la téloméras pour vivre
plus longtemps alors certains animaux
arrivent à vivre plus longtemps mais au
bout de de trois générations ils
finissent stéril euh si nous voulons
être définitivement remplacé par la
machine c'est la solution idéale à mon
avis de devenir stérile par des
manipulations mal comprises et trop
anticipé de l'enzyme télomérase pour
éviter la réduction de taille des
thellomères avec l'âge question internet
son point de vue sur la chute de
natalité en France point interrogation
chiffrinc sur les premiers semestres
2023 c'est
Sérant le monde développé ne fait plus
de
bébé dans jouiss et jeunesses qui est
mon avant-dernier bouquin je terminais
en se disant faites des bébés faites des
bébés faites des bébés n'écoutez pas les
cmer Verts les ayatollah les ayatoll
écologistes n'écoutez pas tous les gens
qui annoncent la fin du monde au coin de
la rue manifestement les gens les
optimistes comme moi ne sont pas écoutés
puisque la natalité s'effondre alors les
chiffres être optimiste comme toi quand
on a ton compte en banque les chiffres
écoute une seconde les chiffres de
natalité serait encore pire si on
retirait l'immigration parce qu' une
partie significative des bébés sont en
fait en France des bébés issus de
l'immigration le nombre d'enfants par
femme des Français qui ne sont pas issus
d'une immigration récente il est
effondré et dans certains pays comme la
Corée du Sud on m mène nettement en
dessous d'un enfant par femme puisque la
Corée du Sud Est à 0,79 enfants par
femme ce qui se traduit par une
diminution par quasiment trois de la
population en une génération
puisqu'il faut 2,1 enfant par femme
environ pour reproduire et que là on est
à
0,79 donc oui le monde développé ne fait
plus
d'enfants c'est pas pour des raisons
économiques qu'on gagne beaucoup plus
d'argent comme une 925 c'est de mon
point de vue pour des raisons
psychologiques on a convaincu les jeunes
générations que le monde cour à sa perte
un sondage en Australie montrait que 27
% des adolescents étai persuadés que le
monde aurait disparu avant pour des
raisons écologiques avant leur majorité
donc beaucoup d'enfants ont peur moi je
vois beaucoup de gamins qui veulent se
stériliser qui veulent pas faire
d'enfant parce que la fin du monde
arrive je dis halte au feu le monde ne
va pas disparaître la crise écologique
on va la régler il y a des pays comme la
France qui montrre l'exemple avec le
nucléaire la France émet beaucoup
beaucoup moins de CO2 que l'Allemagne
elle elle montre l'exemple de la
réduction du CO2 sans attendre la fin du
monde donc il y a des solutions
technologiques pour réduire le CO2 et
donc agir sur le climat je rappelle que
quand un Français allume la lumière ou
son ordinateur il émet 8,6 fois moins de
CO2 qu'un
Allemand parce qu'en Allemagne
l'ordinateur et l'ampoule électrique
elle marche au charbon alors qu'en
France ça marche au nucléaire qui n'émet
quasiment pas de CO2 donc il y a des
solutions techniques on va les trouver
la fin du monde n'est pas là faites des
gamins et cet effondrement démographique
euh des pays développés me mine me
démoralise et je suis malheureux de voir
des gamins qui qui se priv de l'immense
joie qui est d'avoir des enfants parce
qu'ils pensent que la fin du monde est
est est devant nous les gens qui
tiennent des propos et écologistes
catastrophique ont une responsabilité
terrifiante j'en veux beaucoup à
l'écologie euh apocalyptique parce
qu'elle elle décourage nos gamins de
vivre et de faire des enfants j'en veux
beaucoup à Jean-Marc jeanovicii de tenir
les propos qu'il a tenu sur les soins
aux personnes âgées malades je lui en
veux beaucoup d'ailleurs j'ai j'ai j'ai
poussé un un j'ai poussé une gueulande
dans l'Express expliquant que
cette cette volonté d'arrêter de soigner
les personnes agieses très malades
étaient scandaleuses et que je ne
confierai pas ma maman qui est âgée à à
Jean covissi et quand Jean covissi dans
une interview dit que la solution la
plus simple pour la France sur le plan
écologique c'est d'arrêter les soins aux
personnes âgées très malade je suis
juste scandalisé par cette dérive
inhumaine de l'écologie donc ces
discours où on veut arrêter de soigner
les plus fragiles d'entre nous nos aînés
nos parents ce discours on explique au
gamins qu'il faut pas faire d'enfants
parce que la fin parce que la fin du
monde arrive ce discours il est
scandaleux et moi il me dégoûte ce
discours autant le discours sur les
personnes âgées malades qu'il faudrait
abandonner à leur sort le discours de
Jean covissi me donne la nausée il me
dégoûte ce discours de jeanovissi
j'aimerais que zangovicii dise Vienne
dans les médias dis j'ai dit une
connerie je retire ce que j'ai dit dans
l'interview de social terre j'avais
picolé parce que j'étais avec les
copains à midi euh j'en sais rien qui
dit je me suis je retire ce que j'ai dit
sur les personnes âgées malades je le
retire j'aimerais qu'il dis ça mais il
ne l'a toujours pas fait Jean covicier
et donc non franchement ça ça me dégoûte
et je suis aussi écœuré par tous les
discours qui poussent les gamins à pas
faire de bébé avec lesffondement
démographique dont on parlait et qui est
terrible pour nos sociétés
euh moi je ne veux pas de ces deux
discours et j'en veux beaucoup aux
écologistes de ne pas donner d'espoir ni
aux personnes âgées qui seraient des
indésirables dans notre monde
ni aux enfants qui devrai arrêter de
faire des familles de fonder ses
familles non aidons aidons nos aînés
soyons les plus bienveillants avec eux
n'arrêtons pas leur traitement
n'écoutons pas jankovicii faisons
avancer la médecine notamment grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle pour faire
reculer les maladies mortelles et le
cancer ce qui va arriver et poussons nos
gamin à faire plus d'enfants euh moi mon
message à la jeunesse mon premier
message c'est faites des bébés ayez
confiance le monde de demain va être
fantastique n'écoutez pas tous ces
grands moineau de
2023 qui se croit dans Game of Thrones
euh
tu parlais de génétique ton point de vue
et d'après les études que tu peux citer
c'est génétique l'intelligence c'est
majoritairement génétique oui hélas
j'aimerais le contraire j'aimerais
j'aimerais qu'en mettant qu'en donnant
un très très très très bon instituteur à
un gamin pas intelligent il rentre à
Normal Sup ou Harvard j'aimerais
vraiment ça si on donne un un gamin très
intelligent ça donne quoi si on donne un
très mauvais instituteur un gamin très
intellig
ça se passe assez
bien je je te rappelle que parmi les
grands surdoué des derniers
siècles beaucoup ont appris à lire
beaucoup ont appris à lire la science
sans qu'on leur apprenne à lire sans
instituteurs sans précepteur sans
personnees les exemples sont nombreux
parmi les parmi les gens à plus de 160
de cui tu en as plein qui ont appris
tout seul à lire très très tôt en
regardant des livre qui ont appris la
science qui ont appris les mathématiques
sans enseignant
donc en réalité un un gamin très
intelligent sans enseignant est capable
de faire des grandes choses hélas un
gamin pas très malin même avec un très
bon instituteur et limité dans son
développement tu connais le proverbe
alors je l'ai pas de
tête parfaitement c'est un livre sans m
c'est très dangereux
ouais je pense que Pascal a 3 ans avec
un livre 100
m ça va faire la part des choses reven
revenons sur la démographie je te donne
une anecdote il y a un peu moins d'une
quinzaine d'années
j'interagissais dans un groupe non non
commence pas à me regarder l' parce que
je vais me fâcher je te jure et puis je
viens de te prendre la main dans le pot
de confiture là
diversion ça hein donc ça fait déjà ça
fait déjà 2h ça fait
1h41 mais att commence pas à te plainre
sinon je te tape je ne me plains pas
c'est extrêmement sympa comme d'habitude
merci tu me flattes tu c'est de la FLA
gordernerie à ce niveul pas du tout bon
ça va alors il y a il y a un peu moins
de 15 ans j'interagissais sur des
questions économiques dans un un groupe
de travail de très très très très très
au niveau et j'avais dans mon groupe de
travail un banquier de très très très
très haut niveau et de calibre
international et et on discutait sur la
la dévaluation du
dollar et il me dit je lui dis mais tu
vois ce qui se passe avec le dollar il
me répond oui bien sûr les Américains
veulent qu'une seule chose c'est
d'évaluer le dollar à tout prix et à
l'époque j'était jeune con et turbulent
et peut-être un peu naïf et je lui ai
dis mais tu te rends compte les
répercussions que ça va avoir sur
l'Afrique et il me dit écoute la
démographie nuit à la qualité des
cerveaux
est-ce que tu pourrais lui expliquer ça
différemment tu AC tu acquesses pas
est-ce que c'est un point de vue
rétrograde comment tu pourrais percevoir
cette phrase là qui m'a à l'époque
tétanisé tétanisé parce que je me suis
rendu compte qu'à un certain niveau il y
avait quand même une une idéologie à la
limite du racisme de classe à la limite
de
la je te laisse
commencer oui bien sûr qu'il y a une
idéologie certains démographes ont une
idéologie raciste et et et n'acceptent
pas que laprque prenne un petit peu de
temps pour faire sa transition
démographique alors même que c'est
normal quand tu es dans un village et
qu'il n'y a pas de système de retraite
et que beaucoup d'enfants meurent en
basâge il est normal de faire plein
plein d'enfants pour payer sa retraite
quand la mortalité infantile s'effondre
ce qui est en train de se passer en
Afrique il faut du temps pour que les
familles comprennent que quand elles ont
8 ans enfants il va y avoir enfants
vivants et pas comme avant deux puisque
c'est ça qui se passait et pendant cette
phase de transition démographique un peu
chaotique la population explose he on
l'ONU estime que le Nigéria va atteindre
750 millions d'habitants le Congo
Kinshasa devrait atteindre 250 millions
d'habitants on pourrait multiplier les
exemples et l'Afrique pourrait atteindre
4 milliards 4 milliard et demi
d'habitants en en en 200 donc il faut
accepter aider l'Afrique à faire sa
trans démographique ça va prendre un peu
de temps la population est en train de
se stabiliser voire de baisser dans la
quasi-totalité des zones géographiques
sauf l'Afrique noire sauf l'Afrique
sub-saharienne il est clair que la
transition démographique en Afrique va
être compliquée et que la gestion des
service public va être difficile dans
des pays où la population va exploser ça
fait plusieurs années que les ordures ne
sont pas ramassées à Kinshasa Kinshasa
devrait atteindre 80 millions
d'habitants je ne suis pas sûr que le
service de ramassage des ordure va être
remarquable dans les décennies qui
viennent avec une telle explosion
démographique donc il y a une vraie
réflexion sur l'aide au développement
dans ces pays qui ont du mal à faire
leur transition démographique qui doit
être mené pour les aider dans cette
phase très très très compliquée où on
continue à faire beaucoup beaucoup
d'enfants alors que la mortalité
infantile s'effondré s'est effondrée un
pays comme le Niger va atteindre 50
millions d'habitants alors que c'était
un pays où il y avait très très très peu
de monde quand la France a décolonisé en
1960 tout ça ne va pas être
simple j'aimerais te faire
réagir à de l'actualité c'est c'est très
rare qu'on fasse ça hier il y a plus de
6000 personnes qu' ont débarqué à
Lampedusa je voudrais avoir ton avis
là-dessus comment tu perçois les
choses je pense qu'il
faut par la force
militaire
les renvoyer en
Afrique si nous ne faisons pas ça nous
aurons des dictatures d'ultra droite
dans l'Europe de 2035 ou 2040 partout et
moi je suis un libéral je ne veux pas
d'extrémiste au
pouvoir nous faisons tout ce qu'il faut
pour que l'ultraadroite arrive au
pouvoir pas des gens comme
Bardella pas des gens comme Marine Le
Pen l'ultra droite ce qui n'est pas le
cas de Bardella ou de Marine Le
Pen les partis de droite nationaliste
comme le RN vont être débordé par
l'ultra droite si le déferlement
démographique n'est pas arrêté tout de
suite pour l'arrêter il faut que dans
les villages en Afrique on sache qu'on
ne peut pas rentrer en Europe et que
quand on y arrive après avoir filé plein
de poignons au passeurs à ces salot de
passeurs on est
renvoyé sinon il va y avoir des
centaines de millions de personnes
d'Afrique noire qui vont arriver en
Europe dans le continent européen or
l'opinion ne l'acceptera pas et nous
aurons des
dictatures donc
aujourd'hui il faut être très dur il
faut être inflexible il va y avoir en
Afrique des centaines de millions de
personnes qui veulent arriver en Europe
d'arriver à l'ampedoua c'est
extraordinairement facile de traverser
la Libye où il n'y a plus d'État
qui est d'un pays totalement anarchique
c'est extrêmement facile l'ampedusa à 6
à 7000 par jour ça n'est que le tout
début on va se retrouver avec des
journées à 10000 20000 30000 50000
personnes et l'opinion finira par penser
que le grand remplacement n'était pas
une tèse complotiste mais un projet des
gouvernements européens avec des
conséquences politiques absolument
catastrophique donc je pense qu'il faut
arrêter de déconner je pense qu'il faut
regarder la réalité en face l'opinion
n'acceptera pas le déferlement
démographique de venant d'Afrique noire
il ne l'acceptera pas nous prenons un
risque politique absolument majeur moi
personnellement je suis affelé de voir
de plus en plus de gens des classes
moyennes passer à l'ultr drroite et ce
n'est pas ce que je veux pour l'avenir
de
l'Europe est-ce que tu connais Stéphanie
gibaau c'est qui ça une lanceuse
d'alerte qui a travaillé dans la banque
qui a permis à l'état français de
récupérer 1,8 milliard d'euros
elle vit au RSA à l'heure actuelle et et
Bercy s'est opposé à ce qu'elle soit
rémunérée pour ce qu'elle a fait gagner
à la France aux États-Unis tu le sais
comme moi ce type de de d'action
citoyenne est rémunéré ce qui ce qui est
complètement con d'ailleurs sur le plan
parce que les informateurs ont toujours
été payés par la police en France il y a
une cagnotte pour payer les informateurs
dans la police on paye on paye des tas
de gens je mais je connais pas son
dossier partic particulièrement donc
j'ai pas j'ai pas d'avis je ne connais
pas les détails du
dossier si tu creuses un peu est-ce que
tu serais pour que ce type de de femme
qui a été persécuté qui a été ennuyé qui
a été
emmerdé récupère qui a travaillé pour l'
in général je connais pas je sais pas ce
qu'elle a fait je connais pas l'envers
du dossier je je vais dire que des
conneries sur ce dossier dont j'ignore
tout parce qu'avant tu disais pas que
des conneries question non non mais sur
le reste j'ai des convictions je dis
peut-être des conneries alors que là là
je suis certain de dire des conneries
parce que je ne connais rien au dossier
alors je ne suis pas certain de dire des
conneries le futur le futur montrera
peut-être que je me suis complètement
trompé parce que la futurologie est un
exercice difficile on le sait tous mais
mais sur sur ce dossier là là c'est une
certitude que je vais dire des conneries
question internet c'est quoi un travail
respectable tout travail est respectable
moi j'ai appris à mes
enfants quand j'étais tout petit à
respecter tous les
travailleurs y compris les plus
humbles je l'aurais expliqué je les ai
convaincu et c'est vrai que si moi
j'avais été au
chômage je ne serais pas resté au ch age
j'aurais été hboueur j'aurais été
balayeur de rue j'aurais été laveur de
carreaux j'aurais fait n'importe quel
boulot plutôt que d'être au chômage
parce qu'il y a une dignité dans le
travail et qu'un travailleur humble qui
est au SMIG qui fait un boulot simple
pas conceptuel il a une fierté il a une
dignité quand il rentre au boulot très
supérieure à un chômeur à quelqu'un qui
glande et je préfère un quelqu'un de pas
conceptuel qui travaille pour gagner sa
vie et nourrir sa famille à quelqu'un de
malin qui glande et ne fait rien de sa
vie et ne contribue pas au au bien
commun donc n'importe quel travail est
respectable je parle pas des travails
des travaux inégaux de la mafia qui
n'est pas du travail qui est de la qui
est de la rapide mais n'importe quel
travail est respectable moi je ne
hiérarchise pas le travail et et je suis
très
sincère moi titre personnel si j'avais
été un père de famille pauvre au chômage
oui je n'aurais pas hésité à me lever à
5h ou à 4h du matin pour êtrebur et
j'aurais eu une vraie impression de
dignité et quand je vois un travailleur
manuel qui fait un boulot pas du tout
intellectuel qui fait un boulot très
simple je le vois en tant que
travailleur digne ça peut paraître con
parce que je fais partie de la très-aute
bourgeoisie et je suis fortuné et cetera
ça peut paraître con quand je dis ça ça
peut paraître non sincère mais mais
c'est totalement sincère quand je vois
un éboueur je le vois comme travailleur
digne et j'ai un immense respect pour
pour ce qu'il fait et je me suis évertué
à à convaincre mes gamins de cette
dignité dans le travail j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour les gens qui se lèvent tôt
et qui vont bosser j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour les gens qui sont au 38 et
et qui vont bosser j'ai très peu de
respect pour les gens qui ne bossent pas
très très très peu de de respect mais
j'ai un immense respect pour les
travailleurs simple humble et qui se
casse le cul pour donir leur famille et
je trouve que il mérite plus de
respect de la part de la société je
pense d'ailleurs qu'on devrait
rééquilibrer il y a des tas de gens qui
refusent de bosser qui ont plein d'êtes
social alors que ce sont des glandeurs
je pense que il vaudrait mieux que les
travailleurs pauvres soient aidés par
l'État avec des compléments de salaire
versé au détriment des gens qui
volontairement ne contribuent pas au
bien commun et à la bonne marche la
société
teradin non mais étant fortuné ça n'a
pas de sens si tu veux c'est quoi
fortuné tu es en bon rapport avec le
fisque non mais je j'ai vendu des
entreprises j'ai vendu pas mal
d'entreprises j'ai vendu des entreprises
mes
entreprises un certain nombre plus de
100 millions d'euros c'est publique
c'est connu on et cetera donc oui je
n'ai pas de problème d'argent donc le
problème d'être radin ne se pose pas
parce que je parce que j'ai des sous
hein je suis pas Bernard Arnaud Bill
Gates mais j'ai un peu de sous donc
c'est pas très c'est pas c'est pas très
difficile c'est pas très difficile
d'être généreux quand tu as des
sous en revanche quand tu es un
travailleur pauvre dont on parlait
d'économiser peut sembler radin c'est
pas de la ridinerie c'est une nécessité
pour nourrir une famille quand quand tu
es au SMIG donc le mot radin je pense
que il mérite d'être vu à la hauteur de
du patrimoine de chacun toublieras pas
de faire un coup de carte bleu sur
tipi.com
comm/stinervview question Internet et le
prix de la prépa pour Polytechnique
virgule médecine et cetera et cetera
est-ce qu'il y a pas une sélectionuss
par le
fric il y a des gamins qui rentrent à
l'X en passer par une prépa euh il y a
des prépas totalement gratuites dans le
secteur public hein d'ailleurs les
meilleurs prépas sont dans des lycées
publ et sont totalement gratuites hein
les prépas des des meilleurs lycées
parisiens donc il faut arrêter les
conneries un gamin pauvre et très
intelligent peut rentrer en à
Polytechnique en France sans aucune
difficulté c'est moins simple de rentrer
dans les pays où l'école est très chère
mais dans le cas français il y a aucune
excuse quand on est courageux et très
malin n'importe qui peut rentrer à
Polytechnique ou à Normal Sup
hulm les écoles de commerce elles ont
une scolarité qui
coûte même si on peut êt aider donc je
ne parle pas d' chaussé ou de l' ou des
enfants pauvres peuvent avoir plus de
difficultés même si s'il y a des prêts
bancaires et et des bourses mais
franchement pour les écoles dont on a
parlé il y a aucune difficulté pour des
gamins de milieu d'extraction sociale
difficile qui sont courageux et qui sont
malins question internet comment une
société posthumaine peut advenir dans un
monde où les ressources matérielles et
énergétiques
s'amenuis les ressources énergétiques
dans l'univers sont illimitées les
ressources matériel et et de matières
premières sont ils liimités j'incite ton
auditeur à aller voir ce que Jeff Bezos
le fondateur de amazon a raconté sur le
potentiel illimité des astéroïdes en
matière de matières premières je ne
crois pas que nous soyons dans un monde
de pénurie il y a dans le sous-sol
terrestre des quantité absolument
gigantesque de matières premières et le
système solaire est également très
largement pourvu je ne crois pas que
nous allons rentrer dans un monde sans
matières premières dans un monde sans
sans énergie je rappellerai juste un
exemple il y a beaucoup de gens qui
pensaient que on ne pourrait pas
démocratiser la photographie parce que
les selles d'argent il y en avait pas
assez et que les métaux pour faire un
appareil photo il y en aurait pas assez
que pour que tout le monde a un appareil
photo et donc les gens disaient bah les
Africains les asiatiques les Indiens les
gens d'Amérique du Sud pourront pas
faire de photos parce qu'il y a pas
assez de selle d'argent il y a pas assez
d'argent sur terre pour que tout le
monde fasse des
photos la technologie a réglé le probl
problème l'appareil photo d'un téléphone
portable c'est quelques grammes il y a
plus de celle d'argent on a
démocratisé la
photographie et les prédictions
apocalyptiques sur la photo au 21e
siècle à cause de la péorie d'argent ne
se sont pas révélés justes je pense que
ce sera le cas dans la plupart des
secteurs industriels la technologie
l'intelligence artificielle le génie
humain vont nous permettre d'économiser
de plus en plus de matières premières et
en plus les matières premières sont
quasiment illimité dans le système
solaire question internet qui d'ailleurs
n'est pas une question internet donc je
vois pas du tout ce qu' ce qu'elle fait
dans ce ce chat mais je vais quand même
faire le commentaire ok les admis Dex
sortte de H prépas qui sélectionne
elle-même sur dossier sur la base des
résultats du Lycée entre parenthèses
souvent des lycées privés ferme la
parenthèse non son argument ne non les
les meilleurs prépas en France sont des
prépas public c'est c'est quoi les noms
B on les connaît tous vas-y Henry 4
ouigr le lycée le parc à
à à Lyon et et le
lidexchque et le LIDEX au Maroc au nord
de Marrakech qui fournit un un un
compartiment important de d'étudiants de
Polytechnique car le LIDEX réunit les
meilleurs les gamins les plus
intelligent du Maroc et les prépare pour
central l'X et et et normal sup donc non
et et la scolarité au LIDEX elle est
elle est subventionnée par le roi du
Maroc donc l'immense majorité des gamins
qui sont ALX viennent de prépa non
payante Polytechnique 1,9 % d'étudiants
issus de milieux défavorisés mais c'est
parce que dans les milieux défavorisés
on on a plus de difficultés
intellectuell c'est pas une raison
matérielle c'est qu'effectivement dans
les milieux favorisés intellectuels
intelligents on a des enfants en moyenne
plus intelligents que dans les milieux
plus défavorisés et donc il n'est pas un
normal que des gens très intelligents et
des enfants très intelligents qui vont
rentrer à Polytechnique et je dis ça
alors même que étant pas très bon en
mathématique hélas je n'aurais pas pu
rentrer à Polytechnique je ne suis pas
polytechnicien et c'est plus facile de
rentrer à Lenard ce que j'ai fait que de
rentrer à Polytechnique et j'aurais aimé
être un grand mathématicien mais je suis
pas super bon en mathématique mais il y
a effectivement dans les familles
intellectuelles il y a plus de gamins
très intelligents g très bon en
mathématique ce que je ne suis pas qui
vont pouvoir rentrer à à Polytechnique
qu'est-ce que tu peux me dire en tant
que tout bib sur
l'épigénétique
l'épigénétique c'est la modulation de
nos de de de notre
ADN par des facteurs génétiques et par
des facteurs d'environnement alors une
grosse partie de l'épigénétique est en
fait génétique c'est-à-dire que c'est
notre ADN qui s'autorégule hein par le
biais de de plein d'intermédiaires très
très compliqués sur les ADN régul
et sur plein de petits anes très
compliqués il y a toute une toute une
ménagerie de petits anes qui régulent la
la la l'n donc en gros l'épigénétique
c'est
massivement lié à la génétique à laadn
elle-même mais il y a une partie
d'environnement qui régule notre an nous
ne sommes pas le fruit unique de notre
ADN c'est vrai sur le plan intellectuel
c'est vrai sur plein de nos
caractéristiques médicales et cetera
nous sommes un mélange entre notre ADN
et l'environnement et l'un des
principaux vecteurs de transmission de
l'environnement se fait par
l'épigénétique c'est par la modification
par la régulation de l'ADN par
l'environnement au travers des marqueurs
épigénétique donc oui nous sommes un
mélange de notre ADN et de
l'environnement et l'environnement agit
sur notre ADN par
l'épigénétique question internet que
pensent-t-il de l'équation de
a c'est quoi ça deuxème question est-ce
que glandé n'est pas une réponse
actuelle à des gens qui vous exploitent
allègrement si vous êtes exploité cher
ami créer une entreprise en France on
crée une entreprise en quelques jours
avec trois COPEC donc si vous avez des
couilles si vous êtes non ou des overts
s'il te plaît ou des c'est un j'ai cru
comprendre c'était un homme non c'était
pas un homme quoi qu'il en soit bon si
vous avez si vous avez du courage
euh si vous avez du courage si vous avez
de l'énergie si vous êtes motivé si vous
êtes malin si vous avez des idées créez
votre boîte soyez pas exploité je
m'excuse de le dire mais là je vais
paraphraser mon ami Stéphan Malard mais
les gens qui acceptent d'être exploité
d'avoir un patron c'est des gens qui
n'ont pas le courage de créer leur boîte
et d'être leur propre patron donc
arrêtez d'être exploité créer une
start-up il y a plein d'idées il y a des
milliers d'idées grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle grâ à che 4 on peut créer
une boîte en quelques jours allez-y
arrêtez de vous plaindre arrêtez de
jeindre et
bosser on change totalement il va pas il
va pas être content il va vraiment
penser que je suis un sale con mais je
pense sincèrement ce que j'ai dit
question Internet écoute-il les
interviews de
sinkervview oui oui oui d'ailleurs elles
sont remarquables et c'est légitime que
tu ai des audiences aussi
extraordinaires et ce qu'on disait tout
à l'heure je le pense de vrai vraiment
te servir de l genen machin et Jen pour
te traduire dans plein de langues parce
que tu tu vas passer d'un à 5 millions
de vues par par vidéo à 50 millions tu
vas avoir un
impact intersidéral
maintenant on change totalement de sujet
parce que c'est c'est pratiquement la
fin de notre interview déjà quoi déjà ça
fait 2h ça fait 2h 2 minutes une
minute comment tu juges e la la réaction
du
gouvernement et la perception du
gouvernement concernant le covid est-ce
que les systèmes d'alerte ont fonctionné
est-ce que la réponse de notre agès
buisin a collé des affiches à 4 à
Charles de Gaulle quand il y a une
correspondance directe ou Paris était
normal je sais alors d'abord je vais
répondre la guerre des intelligences à
l'heure de jgpt est est dédicacé à
Olivier verrand virgule qui fut
courageux pendant la crise du covid donc
oui
voilà je pense que le gouvernement a été
plutôt courageux courageux et et plutôt
efficace
mais avec ce que je sais aujourd'hui sur
la fin du règne de
Napoléon je ne serais pas mort à
Saint-Hélène si j'étais Napoléon je ne
serais pas allé en
Espagne je n'aurais pas fait ce il a
fait avec la Pologne et je ne seraiis
pas allé à Moscou et je serai mort dans
mon lit au
Louvre avec une dynastie et Napoléon I
me
succédant au lieu de partir chez le
grand-père à Vienne où on lui a
désappris le français le fils de
Napoléon donc oui de refaire le match
avec ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui est très
facile
d'ailleurs si je connaissais l'évolution
de la conjoncture économique et des
marché boursier du
futur je seraiis milliardaire en dollars
en une seule journée en jouant sur les
futures en euros c'est mieux ou en euro
si tu veux chacun d'entre nous pourrait
être milliardaire s'il connaissait le
futur des cours boursiers puisqu'il
pourrait jouer massivement et HG sur les
futures donc oui sachant ce que je sais
aujourd'hui sachant ce que l'on sait on
voit toutes les conneries qui ont été
faites par les gouvernements attends je
peux te stopper on a au début on a cru
Raoul quand il disait qu'il y avait pas
de transmission par l'air mais qu' y
avait des transmissions uniquement par
les mains il avait tort on a cru raou
quand il a dit il pourra pas y avoir de
deuxième vague on a cru Raoul au début
quand il a dit la chloroquine marche
c'est pour ça que Macron est descendu à
Marseille donc le gouvernement s'est
trompé il a cru des experts qui avaient
tort et qui étaient partis en cacahuète
comme euh comme le Cher Didier Raoul
d'autre part le gouvernement a déconné
sur les masques parce que les masquesage
que toi parce que les masques
effectivement étaient utiles même et
mais mais mais qu'on en avait pas
beaucoup parce que on les avait détruits
mais pas uniquement en France en
Belgique c'est pareil en Belgique on
avait on avait détruit les stocks de
masques qui avaient
pourri sur sur les masques on a déconné
sur la diffusion du vaccin on a été un
peu lent et d'ailleurs j'ai écrit des
articles disant
que on avait on avait pris du retard par
rapport à l'Angleterre au début de la
campagne de vaccination donc qu'on a
fait plein de conneries parce qu'on
connaissait pas le futur parce que les
experts étaient contradictoires c'est
tout à fait vrai le gouvernement n'a pas
fait un sans faute mais il a plutôt bien
fait les choses il a plutôt fait bien
les choses dans une ambiance difficile
euh le dernier le non le dernier
confinement sachant ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui on aurait pu l'éviter il y a
plein de choses qu'on aurait pu faire
sachant que ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui
mais à l'époque on ne le savait pas donc
oui le gouvernement nement a fait plein
de conneries il a plutôt bien managé la
crise même si je l'ai critiqué sur
plusieurs points pendant la crise du
covid Commentaire d'Internet monsieur
Alexandre Nil la symétrie d'information
entre les étudiants fils 2 qui ont 100
fois plus de chance d'intégrer
Polytechnique que les étudiants qui ne
connaissant qui ne connaissant pas le
système les méthodes me faites pas
sauter la ligne les méthodes les attendu
du concours il y a évidemment une
inégalité là-dessus c'est totalement
faux quand on est un élève vraiment doué
et motivé on rentre dans les grandes
prépas qui sont gratuites les grandes
PPA publiques des grands lycées comme
Louis leg où on t'explique parfaitement
ce qu'il faut faire au concours de
l'entrée à polytéchnique d'ailleurs les
deux à 3 années que tu vas faire en
classe préparatoire sont entièrement
consacrés à la préparation du concours
d'entrée à Hulme à Polytechnique à
centrale Supelec donc c'est totalement
faux ce que dit ton auditeur
quand tu es pauvre et motivé et malin tu
rentres dans une prépa publique gratuite
où pendant 2 à 3 ans on va t'expliquer
comment fonctionne le concours le jour
du concours tu sauras parfaitement ce
qu'on attend de toi quel est le loyer
d'un logement proche de Louis
legand il y a des internats dans les
lycées publics il y a plein d'aides
potentielles c'est un faux argument
c'est un argument des
fignaces que les gens qui sont pas bon
en mathématiques arrêtent de sortir des
arguments spécieux moi je suis pas bon
ma mathématique j'ai pas pu rentrer à
Polytechnique je me roule pas par terre
et je dis pas que c'est de la faute de
l'État je dis que c'est parce que je
suis pas assez intelligent et pas assez
bon en mathématique arrêtons de chercher
des excuses je me suis pas flingué parce
que j'ai je suis incapable de rentrer à
Polytechnique je suis pas assez malin je
suis pas assez bon en math et ben
j'assume et bien que tes auditeurs
assument et ne cherchent pas des excuses
dans le fait qu'ils sont rentrés à
central ou à l'école des nougas de
montimar au lieu de rentrer à
Polytechnique c'est de leurs faute c'est
pas de la faute de la société civile moi
je n'accuse pas la société et il devrai
faire comme moi et assumer le fait
qu'ils sont pas assez bons pour rentrer
à Polytechnique question un peu provoque
peut-il nous expliquer la physique
quantique pour nous montrer son
intelligence je suis complètement
perturbé par la physique quantique je
trouve ça très compliqué je lis beaucoup
de choses sur la physique
quantique mon plus jeune fils qui est
très bon en physique quantique essaie
désespérément de m'expliquer mais ça
reste laborieux je ne comprends pas tout
il y a des éléments que je comprends un
peu j'en perçois l'importance j'en
perçois l'intérêt mais euh oui euh
n'étant pas très très bon en
mathématiques les équations de la
physique quantique me sont parfois
obscures et et ça me rend malheureux
parce que j'aimerais bien comprendre
cette complexité là j'aurais rêvé être
plus intelligent que je le suis mais je
n'en veux pas à la terre entière
contrairement à certains de tes
auditeurs et je n'en veux pas aux gens
qui sont plus intelligents que moi je
les admire je ne les jalouse pas et je
ne leur en veut pas je suis bon au math
j'ai fait une prépa mais avez-vous
conscience que la vie d'un étudiant
n'est pas gratuite pour la classe
moyenne non
boursière est-ce que tu as des lectures
à nous proposer et non avant ça on fait
on fait une transition assez violente ah
benah tu réponds pas tu étais en train
de réfléchir non mais on va pas écoute
euh
arrêtez d'être égris monsieur l'auditeur
bon est-ce que tu as un mais attends il
devrait il devrait prendre exemple sur
moi qui ne suis pas
aigri de mon insuffisante de mes
insuffisantes insuffisantes qualités de
mathématicien est-ce que tu as un sujet
qu'on a pas abordé que tu souhaiterais
aborder avec nous et notre communauté ou
notre communauté et nous il y a plein de
sujets qu'on n pas abordé faut-il foncer
dans l'eugénisme et l'augmentation
intellectuel comme mosque le propose
comme tu as vu je l'ai écrit dans dans
dans la guerre des intelligences le
lendemain de la sortie de gpt4 elon
mosque a dit l'intelligence artificielle
va trop vite nous allons être dépassé la
seule solution c'est neuraling
c'est-à-dire de mettre des implants
intracérébraux pour augmenter notre
cerveau et être compétitif face à
liya faut-il aller dans cette voielà
ou pas jusqu'où faut-il être
transgressif je ne le sais pas mon
intuition personnelle c'est que pour
éviter un accident social et pour éviter
une révolution de la part des gens
dépassés par la complexité du monde nous
avons plutôt intérêt à diminuer les
inégalités intellectuelles quit à
utiliser des technologies
bioélectroniques transgressives comme le
propose elon
mosque mais c'est un avis personnel et
et j'aimerais bien être challengé sur ce
sur ce point par exemple tu veux que je
te challenge tout de suite par exemple
ouais c'est toi qui est en train de
prendre le contrôle tu me
manipulesout écoute franchement alors le
le tu
exagères quand on voit le résultat sur
les maquiaques de neur à
Link là faut arrêter de déconner pour
justement ne pas être attaqué par les
associations de défense des singes il a
pris des singes chupeclaquant pour faire
ses premières expérientations ils sont
morts et ils allaient mourir les singes
et maintenant on lui dit regardez les
singes à qui on implante neuralink
meurent évidemment il a choisi des
singes qui allaient mourir
pour ne pas sacrifier des singes en
bonne santé faut arrêter de faire chier
mosque avec des arguments
spécieux ton avis surtout ce Brou
augmentation c'est quoi
inf que P je pense que l'augmentation va
être
difficile je pense qu'on va garder des
inégalités intellectuelles
importantes j'ai
peur que si l'augmentation existe elle
augmente plus les gens que les les gens
pas
intelligents si tu fais du tuning sur
une Ferrari tu vas plus l'augmenter que
si tu fais du tuning sur une Lada ça
c'est pas sûr si j'en ai peur j'en ai
peur en tout cas c'est c'est une crainte
qu'on peut avoir donc je pense que la
neuroaugmentation va pas être un long
fleuv tranquille et de toute façon elle
est pas là demain matin parce que
neuralink n'est pas prêt d'être capable
d'augmenter les capacités
intellectuelles des gens moins doués
donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on trouve
une ingénierie politique et sociale
pour gérer un siècle où les inégalités
intellectuelles vont être importantes et
où une partie significative de la
population ne va pas pouvoir courir
après GPT 4 GPT 5 GPT 6 GPT 7 GPT 8 GPT
9 GPT 14 gpt23 GPT 35 je je pense qu'une
crise cognitive comme je te disais tout
à l'heure est devant nous je pense que
90 % de l'énergie des politicien devrait
être consacré à anticiper gérer manager
limiter aurais pu prédire cette risque
cognitive mais qu'on a rien préparé on
pouvait quand même prédire et imaginer
que dans une économie de la connaissance
les gens plus malins auraient plus de
facilité que les gens moins malins et on
n a pas réfléchi et aujourd'hui on est
au pied du mur et on va voir que les
gens moins doués et moins innovants vont
beaucoup souffrir les les gens innovants
vont devoir beaucoup galoper et et on
voit dans l'étude dont je te parlais
tout à l'heure que même les très
brillants étudiants du MBA Warton sont
fortement challengés par gpt4 mais ils
vont s'en sortir et ils vont rester avec
beaucoup d'effort complémentaire de
l'intelligence artificielle en revanche
les gens qui ont pas beaucoup de mémoire
qui ont du mal à lire les manuels qui
ont du mal à se former je pense qu'ils
vont beaucoup avoir de mal dans cette
société qu'est-ce qu'on va faire hein tu
vois tu vois le la masse que ça va la
société civile doit avoir comme priorité
numéro 1 de diminuer les inégalités
intellectuelles au 21e siècle je répète
ça dans tous mes écrits j'en suis
convaincu il n'y a pas de 21e siècle
serein et juste si on garde de fortes
inégalités intellectuelles dans la
société un autre sujet parce que là on
arrive à la fin tu veux parler de quoi
d'autre je veux parler de quoi où tu
veux parler de quoi
d'autre
je crois qu'on a passé en en revue tout
toutes nos Mar toutes mes maroches il
faut il faut que il faut donner un peu
d'optimisme à notre société il faut voir
les bons côtés il faut voir les beaux
compôtés du futur et il faut prendre un
bon bol de [__] pour régler la crise
cognitive qui arrive et à laquelle on
n'est pas préparé voilà est-ce que tu as
bossé sur les répercussions et les
séquelles du covid sur le cerveau les
c'est quel neurologique du covid alors
je vais te dire quelque chose que tu vas
qui va peut-être t'étonner fais gaffe
parce que derrière toi c'est pas un mur
porteur je
pense qu'il y a pas tant de covid long
que ça je par pas du covid long là j'ai
bien compris je pense qu'il y a pas tant
de covid long que ça et je pense
que une partie importante des gens qui
ont des covid long ont en fait une des
pathologies psychi
psycholologique psychosomatique ou sont
déprimés et pour les séqueles
neurologique à moyen terme sur le covid
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit massif vu
le nombre de gens qui ont eu des covid
on verrait dans la société si c'était
massif je dis pas qu'il y a pas un petit
effet on verrait un effet sur la société
neurologique vu les milliards de
personnes qui ont fait une fois deux
fois trois fois le covid moi je ne suis
pas paniqué sur le sujet je pense qu'il
faut surveiller
peut-être qu'on va découvrir dans 5 10
15 ans des S des séqueles
neurologiques des covidl neurologiques
pour l'instant je suis pas paniqué
paniqué sur le sujet mais je ne suis pas
un spécialiste des séqueles du covid et
je ne suis pas un spécialiste des forme
neurologique du covid donc on est hors
on est hors de ma sphère de compétence
c'est mon intuition qui me fait dire ça
mon impression ça n'est pas très
argumenter question de Jay bonsoir
pouvez-vous nous donner des lectures
pour aborder l'intelligence iici ah B
alors
je je pense que la guerre des
intelligences à l'heure de chat GPT est
pas mal alors ça ça c'est c'est
scandaleux ce que tu viens de faire je
le pense je vais le faire à ta place oui
j'ai lu ton livre et oui je me suis
régalé et c'est vrai malgré j'ai même
conseillé à des gens qui te détestent
qui te détestent j'ai dis quand même
prenez le temps de lire ce bouquin c'est
à la fois de la prospective un peu de
science-fiction du du factuel avec le
point de vue idéologique de de de
Laurent Alexandre mais alors il faut le
lire alors moi j'inviterai à lire le
quelqu'un que tu devrais absolument
inviter qui est un très très très
brillant
agrégé normalien de la rue d'ulme et
enarc qui est Raphaël Doan qui a fait un
bouquin formidable qui est si Rome
n'avait pas chuté c'est un un livre où
il imagine en cédent de gpt4 ce
qu'aurait donné Rome si Rome avait
industrialisé la machine à vapeur qui a
été inventé à Rome mais qui n'a pas été
utilisé parce que les Romains n'en ont
pas vu l'intérêt et donc il imagine
c'est une ucronie extraordinaire il
imagine Raphaël Doan ce qu'aurait été
l'Empire
romain si la machine à vapeur avait été
comprise par Rome ce qui n'a pas été été
le cas et c'est un bouquin formidable
sinon au-delà des bouquins il y a
quelque chose qui est vraiment super
c'est de suivre un certain nombre de
comptes
sur sur Twitter le compte d'than molic
le le le compte de kalumchass et cetera
si ton d'auditeur m'envoie un message
privé via Twitter ou les réseaux sociaux
je lui donai donnerai les 5 à 10 comptes
Twitter qui me semblent les plus
intéressant pour suivre l'évolution de
l'intelligence artificielle en ce moment
alors tu vas le faire en open source tu
vas publier un tweet avec les compte que
tu souhaites ok c'est c'est peut-être
politiquement correct c'est parfait
c'est parfait est-ce que tu as d'autres
lectures à
conseiller alors en dehors de
l'intelligence artificielle parce que
comme tu vas faire un un message public
Twitter avec quelques bouquins sur
l'intelligence artificielle et quelques
comptes à suivre des bouquins compés
pour toi al non un deux
films ex Makina et her qui sont
indispensables pour comprendre gpt4 il
faut il faut voir her que je trouve
absolument extraordinaire
euh al tu réfléchis j'aimerais bien que
tu fasses un audiobook avec ton bouquin
une fois pour toute bordel de merde je
vais je vais faire sinon je mets une
intelligence artificielle qui va lire
ton bouquin avec ta voix et je prendrai
les drits d'auteur et je reverserai à
des associations non mais je vais te
dire moi je je conseillerai deux deux
grands classiques le meilleur des mondes
et
1984 pas mal j'accepte j'accepte voilà
j'accepte est-ce que tu as un conseil
pour les jeunes générations une
bouteille à la mer quelque chose
d'impérissable
pour à lire non un conseil pour les
jeunes g un conseil je parce qu'avec ma
femme on a imposé à nos
gamins culture générale culture générale
culture générale la phrase la plus
importante pour se former pour s'éduquer
c'est ce que le général de Gaulle a
écrit dans l'armée de métier la culture
générale et l'école du commandement
c'était vrai en 1934 c'est encore plus
vrai en 2023 il faut pas que vous jeunes
deveniez des technici très étroit gpt4
gpt5 vont faire tout mieux que vous
soyez des généralistes avec beaucoup de
culture générale beaucoup de curiosité
en terme d'humanité et aussi de science
et là vous serez victorieux face à gpt4
donc le conseil que j'ai donné à mes
enfants je le donne à tes jeunes
auditeurs culture générale culture
générale culture générale lisez
énormément au format numérique parce que
c'est plus pratique pour stocker moi je
j'ai des milliers de livres dans mon sur
mon iPad via Kindle je me vois pas trans
porter un 38 tonnes avec tous mes
bouquins quand je voyage donc lisez
plutôt les bouquins de façon numérique
c'est plus pratique pour accumuler la
connaissance mais lisez beaucoup faites
la synthèse entre les humanités et la
science ne devenez surtout pas des
techniciens desséchés étroit est-ce que
est-ce qu'une formation artistique
musicale ça fait partie de la culture
généraleis d'accord je suis nul en en
musique et ma femme s'est évertué à ce
que mes enf enfant échappe à ce
déterminisme et et et deviennent d'assez
bons musiciens donc je mets ça dans la
culture générale Laurent Alexandre merci
merci à
[Musique]
toi